so on the surface level of every human
there's behavior and that's the easiest
thing that we see is behavior but what
creates the behavior is the question
it's a story we're telling ourselves and
what they've learned is the story that
you're telling yourself is created by an
emotion so when you crack that emotion
you go into the belief you have about
the world
and the belief you have about the world
comes from your original incident it's
called the oi your trauma every human
has an original incident a trauma that
creates your belief about the world your
belief about the world creates an
emotion your emotion creates a story
you're telling yourself and the story
you're telling yourself crazy behavior
so we try to get to the fifth level like
when was that moment and it could be
something small but to really go into
those five levels of like okay let's go
to the core but the hardest part about
that is you have to go back to that
child and you have to go really inward
in this meditation and this prayer to
re-encounter that five-year-old version
of yourself and hold them and support
them and know them they're gonna be okay
we can always point fingers on what's
wrong with the world or culture or
government or whatever but it's really
like okay how are you feeling what are
you doing about yourself we're either
receiving a frequency and we're either
like being controlled by the outcomes of
covid or the the stock market or we find
this sense of peace where this world
creates our outer world because we've
seen a lot of people go through
hardships and be in situations where
culturally like oh man that must be
tough and they're like i'm pretty good
like i'm peaceful because they control
this when your internal world is
affected by your outer external world
then you're in trouble or your internal
world can be you can emit a frequency
and create the
reality around you
that was bc serna a man on a mission to
help people feel loved seen heard and
encouraged and start a revival both
internally within you and externally
around you he's the founder of pursuing
purpose a collection of retreats and
online programs helping to heal your
heart reveal your purpose and discover
your tribe we explore jealousy
confidence our egos and divisiveness
unresolved hurts or trauma that reflects
our pain and emotions
community triggers and spirituality
leaning into curiosity and challenging
yourself and embracing the gray all
centered around healing your heart and
transforming your trauma from pain into
purpose and helping others in this
episode we open up a heart centered
conversation on things even as delicate
as spirituality and beliefs
and that's what we're really here for to
lean into each other's stories so that
we can find more compassion in each
other through the way that they view the
world and maybe even learn something
from each other along the way this
conversation felt effortless and i feel
so inspired from all the things bc
shared i hope you guys find joy in
listening to our conversation and thank
you so much for tuning in
let's get started all right we are on
thank you so much bc for coming on the
podcast i am so excited about this
conversation
talking all things healing your heart
and trauma and pursuing purpose
so i firstly want to ask you
what makes you so passionate about this
topic like was there an experience that
you had or what drives you with this
passion yeah well thanks so much for
having me i'm so excited to be here uh
it's been a long journey i've been on
this journey for 14 years now since i
really uh
kind of
became awake to like what's going on
inside my body what's going on in the
world and how do i do something about it
um but i think what started all of it
was i
was a [ __ ] in high school and growing
up i didn't really know about
volunteering or purpose or passions or
like everything that made me a really
bad student in school made me an amazing
entrepreneur and creative and
storyteller and so my whole life the
school system was just i'm broken
because i would get f's and d's and so
what that did to my um
own heart my own soul my own mental
capacity was just oh i don't fit into
society or culture or as a human and so
i always felt alienated um and
yeah it was just a long journey so once
i i traveled for six months in a study
abroad program when i was 19. went to
thailand lived like in these orphanages
and helped with some communities there
and for the first time in my life i was
like whoa there's so much more than just
a's and b's and d's and f's on grades
that's all i knew right and growing up
in the suburbs of denver uh and so that
was really the the part where i was just
like oh i got to do something for people
in the world and uh that's where it
started when i was 19 for sure wow
that's amazing yeah so i i did a study
broadband for six months and then same
thing i was i was going to college to
play basketball but was never still was
failing you know most of my classes and
then the study abroad program was like
hey do you want to work for us and take
college students around the world and so
i was like yeah and so for three and a
half years i took
about 700 college students from 50
different countries all around the world
and we stayed with host families we
volunteered in all these communities and
it was amazing that's so cool and
imagine really meaningful because you're
seeing a lot of impact in a lot of
different ways not just in your own
heart but in other people totally and
staying with host families like locals i
stayed with over 200 host families um
during that time and at one point i was
22 years old so i've been traveling for
like three years and i was like asking
myself i was reflecting and praying and
meditating and had my journal out and i
was like all right what's the biggest
need in the world and i want to go do
whatever that is and so i was like
writing down like do i go help orphans
in africa or help the water crisis in
different parts of the world and what
came down to like this algorithm i was
creating god was like go back to the u.s
and work with high school kids and help
awaken as many high schoolers as you can
and i was like that sounds not nearly as
cool or fun um and so i didn't want to
do that but that's like what i got from
like i feel like god and spirit told me
that so i went back to the u.s at 22
with the sole mission of working with
high schoolers and started bringing high
school kids around the world
because no one ever gave me that
opportunity
so yeah it was a beautiful
challenge but it was amazing and what is
like the biggest need when you're
working with high school kids that you
see that could help open their hearts or
what exactly does that mean opening
their heart what is what's the result of
that totally i think america you know we
have such awesome opportunity like this
is where culture is kind of created you
know in la new york and and so
we have a really big opportunity to use
our resources our um our brains our uh
like advantage on some things to just
give back to the world like social
entrepreneurship you know what like toms
did or companies that are like hey let's
let's create a company and and conscious
capitalism like let's make it mindful to
help people and so yeah i came back to
to just work with high school kids like
what i wish i had when i was high school
or someone to believe in me support me
tell me that grades isn't everything
and then show me how to volunteer and
get involved in my community to really
just open up compassion like really open
up the empathy in my heart to know that
life is much bigger than just sports and
grades because all i knew was sports and
grades my whole life
um and i was just okay at both and so
yeah i really started working with high
school kids and just being vulnerable
like how do you share your heart and
share your um story and and really
invite them into vulnerability like
where sports and men in america don't
really teach that or encourage it
so yeah that's kind of how it started
and now it's been a 14-year journey
since then but um
yeah it's been pretty powerful amazing
so let's jump right in then a little
further into healing your heart like
what that means because a lot of what
you talk about i see is healing your
heart you know finding your purpose and
or living with purpose and healing
trauma so where can we go from there to
start especially since you've worked
with a lot of high school kids a lot of
times that trauma is already playing out
in high school and we're you know our
brains are developing and we have so
much that we can heal from already let
alone into our adulthood if we don't
like
really go deep into looking back into
like what has affected us you know from
our childhood
totally yeah i think i mean i've sat
with over a thousand high school kids in
the last 14 years and hundreds of
parents like countless parents and on
both ends and and really it comes down
to what what is the story being played
out in culture like why are we the
wealthiest country in the world but the
most depressed suicidal country in the
world like there's some conversation
that needs to happen to be like wow
we've really done good at wealth and
really bad at happiness and
peace of mind and so uh looking at
really trying to impact the youth is
where you know it begins and starts and
we kind of sometimes grow up in our
heart gets a little bit harder and we we
stop having open conversations or um we
stop building those bridges like you're
doing and and and so i was like man if i
can just impact youth and start the
journey sooner than later um then i can
really have an opportunity to help them
not go through so many hardships you
know the amount of you know over 50 in
america are divorced and mental health
all these different things where it's
like all right let's go to the the youth
and ask them where they're feeling
disconnected to their
self and where the ego comes and plays a
role that you are separate from your
brother or your sister or your friends i
call brother and sister but um
yeah so so really started these programs
we have a we have a workshop called if
you really knew me um and you sit down
with this these you know there's
probably like uh 200 students but
there's like a whole bunch of groups of
six people
and you lead the whole workshop prior to
doing it with the kids you lead by
example but you really go around in a
circle with these kids and say if you
really knew me you'd know this and
doing 10 years of this and hearing
stories that i you know you can't even
fathom of of from you know a 15 year old
walking in on one of their parents
trying to take their life like what that
he does for his psyche to um you know
throwing a house party and one of your
friends drowns in the backyard in the
pool because they were drunk like so
many stories these kids and they don't
then kids don't have anywhere to share
this
now therapy is becoming more normalized
and not stigmatized which is beautiful
um because we hit the tipping point i
think you know with covid and um just we
were like wow 100 kids in america take
their life every day so we're like okay
so we should probably figure out not the
formula because america the western
world we're just like oh here's a pill
like oh you're sad here's a pill for
that
and the holistic ways which we talked
about with food without being outside
with um community
you know a lot of doctors don't ask what
you're eating or um how your heart is or
your i guess when your heart is like how
your you know
your uh your trauma is your story yeah
so yeah just really starting the
conversation with kids and i'm so
thankful
because you know covet did happen but it
also opened up a huge awareness right
for mental health therapy um and all
these things and even doctors nowadays
if you ask doctors that are a therapist
and any kind of doctor they'll say
you know medication has its role and
therapy has its role but community is
the number one most important piece out
of all that and doctors like if i had to
choose one of those it would be fine
community find people and support that
you can walk through these questions and
these emotions together
so yeah yeah because what happened with
kovid people were so isolated a lot of
people a lot of children who are going
through such an important developmental
stage in their life and you're so right
about the community aspect i don't know
if you've heard of the blue zones but
yeah how they talk about those nine
common characteristics that have created
the most um centurions the longest
living people of the earth and community
is i'm not sure if that was the exact
word used but it's something about
community and living with others being
one of those nine common characteristics
yeah which is so powerful yeah denmark
actually implemented a an apartment
complex program where you you live in an
apartment you have your own room but you
all eat together and commune together
and it's like intentional community um
that has been like supported in and
denmark's like voted the happiest
country in the world every year yeah um
because they believe in community so
much right and you're so right about
america too like a lot so much of it is
materialistic driven
and
very focused on what you have what you
own is what will create your greatness
when that's so not the case like we know
that it really comes down to like
healing your heart like the way i've
never really used that phrase healing
your heart but so much trauma that we
experienced that doesn't even have to
happen from childhood but it could be
something that you've experienced just a
few years ago and you never really
resolved it and it's just like lingering
deep in your soul and anytime something
comes up like a trigger it can affect
your whole mindset of how you view
yourself how you look at others how you
respond to others and so i love what
you're doing because by talking about
healing your traumas in turn you end up
being able to have better relationships
with others which ends up helping
everyone you're around it's like a it's
like a magnifying effect that's the word
like a an effect that makes it ripple
effect
yeah and that's so important too of of
really starting with self right like
we're you know we can always point
fingers on what's wrong with the world
or culture or government or whatever but
it's really like okay how are you
feeling what are you doing about
yourself and and this so either humans
were either receiving a frequency and
were either like being controlled by the
outcomes of covid or the the stock
market or we find this sense of peace
where this world creates our outer world
because we've seen a lot of people go
through hardships and be in situations
where culturally like oh man that must
be tough and they're like i'm pretty
good like i'm peaceful because they
control this and if you don't con either
this world affects controls this world
or this world controls this world and if
this world controls this inner world i'm
sorry if people listen on the podcast
i'm like pointing to my heart when i say
this world i'm so sorry um but when when
your internal world is affected by your
outer external world then you're in
trouble
or your internal world can be you can
emit a frequency and create the
reality around you yeah um and so really
the programs we use and the one of the
algorithms we use is there's five levels
to every single human regardless of who
you are and each level creates a level
so on the surface level of every human
there's behavior that's the first level
and and that's the easiest thing that we
see is behavior but what creates the
behavior is the question and so that
what creates the behavior is the story
we're telling ourselves and it's like
okay what a story am i telling myself
what's create what creates the story i'm
telling myself and what they've learned
is the story that you're telling
yourself is created by an emotion
now most aaa programs and addict
programs they talk about the first two
levels what your behavior is and what
story you're telling yourself the
hardest level to crack is that third one
the emotion so when you crack that
emotion you go into the belief you have
about the world
and the belief you have about the world
comes from your original incident it's
called the oi your trauma so re every
human has an original incident a trauma
that creates your belief about the world
your belief about the world creates an
emotion your emotion creates a story
you're telling yourself and the story
you're telling yourself crazy behavior
so we try to get to the fifth level of
like when was that moment and it could
be something small when you fall off
your bike and your dad you know says hey
get up i'm not gonna help you and you're
just like oh my god they bleep out the
world i'm by myself when i get hurt or
if you know my mom was healing from
something and i go hug my mom and i
didn't know she i was four years old and
everyone yells at me and goes careful
and i'm like well i'm just hugging and
so then my my story is like oh my gosh
when i love someone i hurt them and so
it could be so small and big obviously
if you lose someone or if your family
talk down to you but to really go into
those five levels of like okay let's go
to the core but the hardest part about
that is you have to go back to that
child and you have to go really inward
in this meditation and this prayer to
re-encounter that five-year-old version
of yourself and hold them and support
them and know them they're gonna be okay
and so a lot of the the guided
meditation prayers we do is really going
back to that five-year-old self because
at the end of the day people walking
around hurting people they're just a
bunch of hurt kids totally and uh
totally and so
we the at the epidemic we have now in
america is we have a bunch of boys
inside of man's bodies it's like what i
always say to my men's groups i run like
men's groups and i was like we have all
these little boys but they're in 30 year
old men's bodies and they don't know how
to regulate their systems their triggers
they don't know what they're doing to
the feminine energy when they you know
kind of use them in certain ways and
what i've noticed is and we can go in so
many different directions like with
masculinity so i don't want to like get
too far away i know like there's so many
yeah what i've noticed is
the the relationship men have with their
mother is so crucial to the relationship
they have with women and the feminine
energy and if they've never really
healed that they continue to hurt women
just on the regular and i've worked with
thousands of men for the last 10 years
too and that's like a whole different
topic conversation but um
anyway just really trying to get back to
that that heart you know in that soul of
uh
hey where did because you know your kids
you know kids are our greatest teachers
jesus said the only way to enter the
kingdom of heaven which i believe is
right now heaven is we're supposed to
bring heaven to earth but jesus was like
the only way to enter the kingdom of
heaven is with a childlike spirit and
the reason he said that is because you
can't have pride you can't have
knowledge you can't just because these
these uh pharisees in the bible would be
like i know scripture and i know the law
and i know this and jesus is like hey
these kids over here are your teachers
you're not getting into heaven unless
you live like them and i just love that
because we're supposed to return home
to that five-year-old self and then live
with like this i mean literally um scout
is like going into the stories of how
she's watering all these plants and
loving these plants i'm like she's made
it she's she's made it to the pinnacle
of life all right guys are you looking
for more plant-based recipes to add into
your life and nourish your family i'm
doing a special ebook promotion for my
podcast listeners to thank you for all
of your support where you can get any of
my ebooks for 15 off with the code
podcast just go to ellen fisher.com
ebooks and enter the code at checkout to
get this deal while it lasts all three
of my ebooks are filled with our
family's favorite and staple plant-based
recipes that are whole foods focused
nourishing delicious and satisfying many
of these recipes we eat on a weekly or
even daily basis and it's filled with
the meals that i found over the years to
make my family feel our best taste
incredible and most of them are quick to
whip up in the kitchen too a family
favorite is the vegan lasagna in my epic
vegan cravings ebook and also you have
to make a big batch of home baked omega
granola which is sure to get eaten
within the week healthy hummus recipes
and a totally decadent springtime lemon
poppycake layered with strawberry jam
and cream cheese frosting made from
coconut and lemon zest that the kids
love for me to make for their birthdays
the linguine parm and veganzuki which is
a chocolate chip skillet cookie topped
with the healthiest homemade vanilla ice
cream that tastes like it's from a
creamery
is to die for and i love making for
family dinner every week the hearty red
lentil chili from the epic plant bear
kid food ebook these ebooks are 100
vegan whole foods focused gluten-free
friendly and are instant digital
downloads that can be read on any
smartphone tablet or computer between
all three ebooks i also include
practical tips encouragement inspiring
content simple swaps to enhance the
health of your meals a seven day sample
meal plan how to help your children love
fruits and vegetables lunchbox ideas
beginner vegan tips and more and i have
poured my heart and soul into these
books between all three ebooks there's
over 460 pages of content and vibrant
photography and each recipe is filled
with vibrant whole plant foods for
health and wellness in both body and
mind remember to use the code podcast at
checkout for 15 off any or all of my
ebooks i hope you enjoy them and feel
inspired to get in the kitchen to make
healthy nourishing plant-based meals and
somewhere along the way we get
distracted and lost and ego and money
and traumas come into play and then
literally if you talk to older people
that are past 50 they're just in the
garden watering the plants and they're
talking like scouts talking
yeah which is your daughter i don't know
yeah
yeah everyone knows that i'm sure yeah
because they're starting to realize like
oh this is this is actually the key it's
not so much what i thought it was as i
was getting into adulthood and
everything like that
totally i mean i i had so many things i
was like yes and then i'm like wait
where do we even go i know so many
things that you touched on but i think
that inner trauma that you're talking
about is so relevant you would love the
um
mind change method which is my friends
kent heather mckean i had them on my
podcast about how your mind could change
everything and i've done
many mind change sessions with my friend
heather and she's so gracious and loving
and doing these with me which is
essentially what you're talking about
going back to that child's self those
what are those moments finding those
moments where you're like wait i had no
idea that this affected me that much or
maybe you did but you just always like
pushed it aside and you didn't really
know how it really related to your adult
adult life but you know it affected you
and when you think about it brings up
emotions but when you go back to it and
like really let yourself like hold
yourself let yourself feel those
feelings and then you kind of rewire
your brain you rewire your brain to tell
yourself what it what it actually could
have been or what it meant um
to change how you receive that memory in
a different way into your adulthood it's
really really fascinating like it's
basically changing your memories
so that you're not um like still dealing
with that trauma from what happens when
you're younger and i found like just
incredible results from doing something
like that so i know it's not exactly the
same thing but it's similar it's like
going back to those traumas and what you
experience well yeah i think we i think
we all know that we can't think our way
out of heartbreak or losing a parent
like we we know when we lost our parent
or broke our heart from a relationship
we like we know it's not forever but we
literally cannot knowledge our way out
of it and as society and western world
has taken this like kind of pride on
like oh we can have a pill anything you
want to feel anything you want to if you
don't want to feel sadness here's this
but you can't think your way out of pain
and so no matter how what they've
realized in science is that actually 80
of all the information is our body
sending information to our brain and
most people think it's all of our brain
sending into our body and so what
they've realized is that trauma is
stored in the body like actual energetic
like if you have hip problem or back
pain they've realized that when that
when you fell as a kid or your mom
didn't pick you up and say i love you
there's a part of your body that holds
this trauma and so when you go into
meditation and prayer and really you
know not trying to think your way out
because any anyone smart can know what's
wrong with trauma but you have to
re-feel it you have to feel emotions
again and we're emotional beings more
than we are cerebral and i think people
think we're cerebral because we can
we're really smart and we've we've tried
really hard and that's why we're at the
tipping point of mental health and the
conversation we are because we've
literally
forced these these medications to people
and we forced uh
the knowledge that we can like put a man
on mars soon you know but it's like wow
we haven't actually figured out this
that well yet and so now science what i
love right now the the renaissance that
we're in is spirituality and science
we're at war for so long spirits you
know science was like you can't see love
you can't measure it it's not real and
spirituality was like love and heart and
now for the first time what i've what
i'm seeing is spirituality and science
are actually kind of like hey we've hit
a ceiling and we want to learn from you
and now to get deeper in your spiritual
practice you need to learn about science
and to get deeper in your scientific
awareness you need to learn more about
spirituality and so there's this huge
awakening happening that i've noticed
being in those realms for over a decade
that i'm excited about that i'm like
whoa there's machines now that can
measure
the energy coming off of your heart and
there's heart math i don't ever heard of
heart math at ucla they had there's like
this study it's one for like over a
decade now but basically they hook up
these machines to your to your body into
your brain
and they've realized that they're that i
mean this is kind of crazy studies but
there's one that there was a machine
that wasn't connected to the person and
they would tell the person something
like hey your car got stolen or they
would tell them things and this uh this
was yogurt that the machine was
connected to because there's living uh
probiotics on it and the yogurt would be
affected it would like the energy would
move on and they're not connected to it
and then they did one where uh at heart
math university they studied where um
they showed images to a person that was
hooked up to the machine brain and heart
and they showed them like a cup like
neutral images and then horrific like a
dead body in a car crash and they
realized that three to five seconds
before you saw the dead body or the car
crash your heart knew it was going to
happen
which is so that's when that's what
they're trying to figure out
so like they'll show a cup and nothing
happens to your mind or your heart and
then right before three to five seconds
before they show a snake or
something intense your body would your
heart would react before your brain
could see it wait that's weird i know i
i would love to see those studies maybe
we can find it and put it in the shout
outs for people to look at there's in a
documentary called i am by tom shadiak
one of my mentors
and he goes and interviews them and it's
probably my favorite doc i've screened
it around oh awesome i am i am check
that out yeah
um i think that all of that is
fascinating i think you're right that we
have
so much more of our spiritual energy and
our emotional energy is it's so much
more powerful than we realize like we
look at ourselves as bodies and then we
have like this you know this place in
our heart that is our soul right but
this place in our heart that has
emotions but really like we're admitting
it everywhere there's a lot of times you
can
feel a presence of someone and you're
like why do i feel so good around this
person like what what is going on that
it's just like the vibes right like you
hear the it's a vibe
and there's still so much that we have
to learn and that's not to say that
there isn't a place for like um medical
prescriptions and drugs i just want to
make sure to preface that just because
of course we're not doctors and there
are physicians that are it's very
important right to acknowledge something
like that but you're so right of the
over
the over prescription over medical use
that we have instead of really
connecting into
a lot of the things that are really just
our traumas that we need to heal it's
not for every situation of course but um
and i think going back to that it
reminds me of the difference between the
conscious thoughts and the subconscious
thoughts so when you're saying like the
thinking you can't think your way out of
your trauma right you can't just be like
i'm just gonna heal it i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna yep i'm healing it right
now right like it ha it's really it's
deep deep deep in that subconscious like
so many of our thoughts are these
subconscious thoughts we don't even know
that we're having
so all of that plays a role yeah 90 of
all of our thoughts are subconscious oh
wow that much yeah so it's like an
iceberg have you seen like an iceberg
like ten percent of the iceberg shown in
underwater so when there's like breath
work or plant medicines that are helping
people basically just lower the water
because if ninety percent of all the
decisions you make every day are
subconscious then we need to figure out
what's going on in the subconscious
because that's a lot from the outfit you
put on to the food you eat to
how you treat people or how you think
about people
90
is in
is underwater so we need to access that
and it helps you i think to have a
little more empathy for other people
because
we when you look around everyone is
really just doing
what they're doing based on the stories
that they've been told throughout their
whole life or the stories that have
happened to them and it affects how they
look at the world like we all literally
have these completely different lenses
on the world based on our experiences
and that is so important when it comes
to empathy and like understanding each
other yeah yeah you really in the
spiritual community you know i'm always
trying to encourage
you know christians that some come off
what somewhat judgmental or yeah because
even you saying even you saying that
like heaven is here the kingdom like
that that's actually quite controversial
i don't really normally talk about
spiritual i haven't yet touched on that
although i would love to i was just i
think i was talking to you about how i
would love to do an episode with like
three different spiritual beliefs and
just kind of have a conversation not
like a debate but just a conversation
like where do we align why do we think
the way that we do with like completely
different religious beliefs or spiritual
outlooks in life and i don't know i
think it's really fascinating but i
haven't really touched on it yet yeah
because even just saying what you just
did is quite controversial for people
totally yeah and i think you know the
goal is the compassion of listening to
people and i think christians and not to
like you know like i was a youth pastor
for a while and i'm still really close
with jesus in my own walk but i think
christians have this you know way of
shaming people or guilting people and
when you tell someone they're wrong for
what they believe you actually
dehumanize them you you take whatever
life experiences they've had to get to
where they what you just said what they
believe about the world about religion
about god about politics and you say hey
you're wrong you're dehumanizing their
whole life experience and and you and
you know i'm always trying to encourage
christians like hey jesus two best two
qualities was asking questions and
listening like that was the best thing
he was at and so really just trying to
help people like you said get more
compassionate to where if someone does
something
heartbreaking like in the news and
people portray it as like i'm gonna use
something maybe controversial but like a
shooter like a school shooter
and and you know or someone just does
something bad you can get really mad at
that person
and really triggered or you can just
break your heart like for that person
like just being like and i know
it's all opinions but like that school
shooter of course that was really sad
what he did but
if you can find this healing in your own
heart and just be like dang that kid
must have been going through something
really hard you've accessed this god
level of compassion to just meet people
you know and it's not okay but even if
someone like you know what i said on
my instagram the other day is we we
usually judge people on their worst
moments like the worst thing they've
ever done or said cancel culture
and i think if you heal your heart and
you really go inward you you see the
potential in everyone and so even i've
seen people that have been incarcerated
like arrested and in jail for 10 years
become nannies and i'm like hell yeah
like there is no
like anything is revival and redemption
and so anyway there's no boundaries to
like your life like i mean think about
yeah you're interviewing all these
people to nanny your kids and you're
like oh she's stanford she's harvard and
then this person's ex incarcerated and
you immediately be like oh that's a no
sweetheart like you tell your you know
your wife that's a no it's like why is
it a no like does not everyone have a
chance to become new in life and if we
give people these labels and these
categories and stigmatized even from job
offerings to people that have been
incarcerated or anything
it's just heartbreaking and what you
said is i remember you did i saw a video
or i was listening to something you said
about that about how when we give labels
to other people that were dehumanizing
them like especially because it's so
divine it can be quite divisive oh
there's a couple things i feel like in
this whole conversation the one
um how quick we are to criticize others
right instead of looking inward and be
like what am i doing like instead of
focusing on the like oh that person's
doing it wrong especially in the age of
social media we have this like
there's a there's this there's a culture
now of this justification to be like
anyone who's online you are doing it
wrong and i'm gonna tell you why x y and
z right and someone listening might be
like well maybe that's hard for you
because you are the one online and
you're the one receiving the blah blah
blah but i really think if you take a
step back we all can just like look in
ourselves and be like what do i what am
i doing what can i focus on and what am
i gonna be able to put out into the
world that's going to bring betterment
right exactly um and then the other
aspect you said about
dehumanizing others do you feel like
it's different if you put the label on
yourself like like versus versus when
people are putting labels on others that
they haven't given themselves what do
you think
yeah i think the duality just we talked
about this other day you know the
culture of the second i say i am a
democrat i am a trump supporter i am a
christian i'm an atheist we immediately
lose
the uh opportunity to just discover
something new about someone and yeah my
mentor tom shadiak the one who made the
documentary said um definition is the
death of discovery
and um he also directed like ace ventura
and uh patch adams and liar liar and uh
bruce almighty so he's like he's he's
really good friends with morgan freeman
jim carrey and they have these really
deep conversations that he always tells
me about but that's one that came up
when they had that conversation is
definition is the death of discovery so
the moment i hear
you believe you voted for something or
you believe in a god i lose the
discovery in just who you are i lose the
opportunity to to um because we have a
we have a cognitive bias we
subconsciously we don't control that the
second someone says i am a blank or i
voted for blank we have no control over
our subcon unless you're really healed
we have no control over our subconscious
bias to immediately be like oh they're
this yeah and so we lose all discovery
in who they are and so you know the goal
is to get away from this duality away
from this black and white away from this
like if you're if i think we talked
about it you know if you disagree with
me we're not friends you know what i'm
saying and well that's just what's
happened in our culture right now and
i've talked about it you know a lot on
this podcast just about like meeting
people where they're at like not being
so quick to like look at if this person
did this or that or says whatever voted
for this whatever like
that doesn't mean that they're all these
other things i know you know to just
assume but you're right when you put the
labels on that i kind of struggle with
that because there's certain labels that
i do like for myself like i like calling
myself vegan but you're right when you
say that there are other people other
people are going to have different
stigmas in their own brain of what they
think vegan means
you know so you can like that label for
yourself but
what are you limiting in that other
person when you speak to them and they
already have their preconceived notions
and ideas on what it means if you're
vegan if you're vegan that means you're
this this or that or maybe there's a
time if i'll come out saying like this
is something i believe in
and then people will assume well if you
believe in this and that means you must
believe in all these other things and
i'm like wait wait a second i haven't
even talked about any of that i don't
know what i think about that so that's
why i think the gray is so so helpful as
opposed to just these black and white
and these dualities of good bad right
wrong especially but i think especially
if someone's putting on a label for
someone else that they haven't even like
outwardly given themselves is especially
harmful but i do see what you mean even
just the labels in general but sometimes
there's a help helpful conversation
right when you're like navigating a
topic but but i guess it's better to
just have a broader conversation instead
of just using a word right
yeah some words are charged obviously
more than others veganism and
christianity have always been like
similar boats you know where it just you
immediately think shame or judgmental
like you can be at dinner with friends
and you're just like oh do you have
anything plant-based on the menu and
everyone's like feels judged already and
you're like wait what i didn't judge any
of you but they yeah right the worst but
they might have that from a past
experience of someone who did judge them
or maybe something they watched on tv
about a vegan or something like that
like a movie that portrayed a vegan in a
certain way yeah and things like that so
it all plays into their story totally so
trying your best like i said always go
inward but just instead of being you
know you know fight or flight mode with
even when someone's like i'm a christian
like oh my god you're judging me i'm a
vegan oh my god you're judging me it's
more of just being like oh why why is
that you know why why is that and you
know i love the you know even veganism
because it's some people for animals
some people it's the health some people
it's um the environment so
you know just being curious always no
matter if they voted for someone or
believe something with that word just
realizing why you gave it charge like
you gave a charged experience with that
word which is heartbreaking now like
christians literally when you think of
the word christian you think of
judgmental shame hating people and you
think of jesus you're like wow that guy
was really loving and like washed
people's feet and like loved people
really well that he shouldn't have been
talking to and so you're like what and
vegans you know so anyway it's like just
always coming back to like i think
internet has definitely blown it up
where
you know like if you have a car like we
were saying last night if you sit with
anyone
uh regardless what they believe or who
they voted for um from guns to anything
like that you'll most likely have 80
more in common than differences that is
exactly what i'm always trying to say
i'm like instead of just being like oh
you have this you you're this right
you're a democrat you're republican
you're this you vote this person like
you're just saying it and be curious
like you're saying like why do you think
that because more likely than not you're
gonna find out that oh i get how they
got there i get why they think the way
that they do even if that the other day
you don't agree with it you can still be
like i understand why they got there and
why they think that way and it might you
might learn something you might realize
oh actually i didn't know that about
that i should consider that aspect and
then just being more in the gray of
understanding yeah all that stuff so
where does this play a role with our
traumas because do you feel like a lot
of these judgments that you know we live
in the society we're just like casting
judgment here and there left and right
over everything what is it that causes
that is some of it related to our
unresolved trauma yeah all of it i would
say it's you know like the idea that
concept that we're you know kids are
taught hate are taught judgment are
taught these things from either culture
or from their circles but yeah i think
it all comes from trauma so it all comes
back to healing the words you know when
you're i would say uh scout you know at
her age she goes to a playground she
doesn't care what skin color or who they
voted for or what car they came in she's
just playing with this kid and it's just
this purity of like um
yo if you fall and cut yourself i'll go
tell my mommy you need a band-aid you
know what i'm saying like we're gonna
help each other and somewhere along the
way we get in this fight-or-flight mode
where we uh our egos come up and we're
like oh i have to look out for myself i
have to protect myself and it's
biological and cultural cultural totally
because a lot of it is like it's such a
um huge responsibility to raise children
like huge because all of your traumas
are put like pouring out onto them right
all healed yeah yeah if you're not
healed i mean is anyone ever fully
healed right like we all have these
little things that we're just like that
we can work on still and so when you say
something that maybe like you said even
about the car right like a child who's
never thinking about someone's car but
if they hear from an adult saying
something about the value of someone
with a nice car or like ooh that nice
car like that person has this then you
start telling that story to that child
like oh you're more valuable if you have
a nice car
that type of thing sorry keep going
no yeah so just coming back to uh yeah
where
it's fight or flight so basically so
what i always tell people is there's
three wheels there's cultural biological
and then soul your heart your true
essence and the front wheel like a
tricycle is either leading those two
wheels or um so either your biology is
leading your soul and your cultural two
wheels or your souls leading your
biology and culture so always coming
back to when you make a decision about
your life biologically women are like i
need to get married right i need to have
kids and then culture like oh i need to
have a job i need to have money security
but if you put your soul and your heart
and your truth at the front wheel of the
tricycle and it's pulling the other two
you'll always notice there's a more pure
alignment um and so always coming back
to like quote is this by is this
reaction of if i'm dating this girl or
i'm raising my kid or i'm making a job
description is it cultural biological or
my soul my truth my my love you know my
purity um and then really trying to just
navigate that and and going back to all
decisions we make
and a lot of it obviously has to do with
our upbringing our traumas our
experiences we've had um so always
having compassion for anyone like
they're going into prison systems now
and they're literally teaching
vulnerability and compassion and empathy
and giving them like poetry and
creativity to like express this and not
just write them off of like oh they're
they're just a number in a system and
they're no longer benefit to society
and now they're going like well let's go
you know rehab this this uh this heart
this little kid you know yeah we talked
about the prison system issues with um
my friend dominic thompson that episode
was so fascinating
yeah i recommend anyone listening to go
check that out because there's so many
issues like you said with the prison
system this idea that like oh you
committed this crime or you did this
wrong and then that means we just put
you here instead of actually like what's
gonna help heal the heart yeah right and
that's what they're doing and so you
know and that's why i work with kids for
so long is because yeah you know you can
and i worked with inner city kids so i
basically moved to the east side of
denver which is the inner city like
urban area and i started mentoring a
group of uh 20 students and i spent five
years with them almost uh every day and
really just uh
became brothers and um just simplified
like my
my purpose on the world like people want
to solve like they everyone said i want
to change the world i want to change the
world i want to i want to do big things
it's like yeah well do you want to go do
the dishes for your mom and they're like
no i want to change the world and it's
like that's changing the world like you
have to humble and i i'm so honored that
people want to change the world that's
beautiful but you almost become
paralyzed because you're like wait i
have to feed a billion people and give
water to it's like hey just simplify it
go do this for your mom
you know go in word on yourself become
the purpose like the the purpose is
never external you become the the um
you become purpose and you become in
alignment with whether your kid is
crying on the playground or you see a
kid that his mom is somewhere and he's
crying you're going to help that kid
crying right and so you become just love
in any situation
where you're not being like i can't go
protect that kid that just cut his knee
because i need to watch out for my kid
it's like no that kid cut his knees
mom's not with him you're gonna go love
him and somewhere along the way we've
we've learned to be
mad at you know if my life my if i cut
my left hand my right hand is not gonna
be like hey you're doing bad i don't
like you and i'm not to help you carry
things my right hand's going to have
empathy and health you know i'm saying
and so we're all connected and i know
that might sound woo to some people or
spiritual um but a lot of people are
just in fight or flight mode they're
triggered because um
these traumas these moments in their
life and the biological and you said
cultural but the biology so we're in
junior high um we in high school in our
life when we make a mistake we think
that this tribe could kick us out and we
can die and so our ego is
obviously when we were cavemen and there
was animals that can kill us everywhere
our ego was like okay don't go out this
time and build a hut like this and build
a weapon like this and so our ego was
always trying to protect us and so this
is because we could die and so our ego
um was overflowed into our now brains
now which if i am dancing in seventh
grade in front of all these kids and
they make fun of me my ego goes okay
note to self never dance in public again
because if they shun you if they push
you out of the tribe you'll die like
that's literally what's biologically
happening and they've proven this with
this with the subconscious and the
science and so
then we um we stopped dancing in front
of people and we stopped singing in
front of people and i would always use
this analogy that i would go to
elementary schools and speak and i'd
raise you i'd like raise your hand if
you can sing and all the kids shoot up
i'm raising if you can dance all the
kid's hands shoot up and then i go speak
out of high school with a thousand kids
i'm like raise your hand if you can sing
and maybe one kid raise your hand if you
can dance like one kid and somewhere
along the way we lost the
freedom of like your kids just dancing
and singing and having fun and um
wow what an amazing comparison yeah it's
wild i've done it many times and it's
just like man it's heartbreaking and so
my goal and and now what's happening
with this movement of 35 and 40 and 45
year olds they've been through divorce
and bankruptcy and mental health and now
40 year olds are like wow i got to go do
the work i have to go inward i have to
forgive my five-year-old self forgive my
parents heal this bitterness that i have
this chip on my shoulder and i mean
there's so many movements now that are
happening and so my goal is to
help people not go 35 and 40 years
before they do it um so yeah
yeah it's been a journey i think you're
um comparing your example of wanting to
change the world but looking at like
maybe too broad of a scale or too
grand of a gesture right um but then
bringing it back down to your daily life
and what you're doing and to just do it
to be compassionate to really like focus
on like how you can be more loving and
compassionate i think it's a really good
way to put it and it's really helpful
because it starts within your daily
practices your daily choices and how you
speak to others and how you speak to
yourself and how you help others and to
what you eat
yeah all of it all of it and your your
daily habits with your life and how you
what's the word um become more
intentional yes you know from how you
eat to you know how long
little things how long you shower maybe
to just being more mindful of how you
approach life and i think nature
like is the greatest teacher of that
like if you go sit in nature and really
become i call it sobering your soul and
so when you sober your soul you're not
drunk off of buying things or drunk off
of followers or instagram likes and you
sober your soul and you sit in nature
and you go wow they're all working
together the birds and the trees and the
animals the insects like all of them are
working together and they're not at war
with themselves and this tree they've
scientifically proven this that the
trees that connect under the ground will
give water to other trees and they will
like support each other and so
nature for me is god like his church is
everything like you go into and that's
when you find this plant-based diet
where you're like whoa like
you know the everything is vibrational
and there's this documentary called
thrive and thrive too i don't ever heard
of it no but this new one that just came
out they zoom in on an atom and they
zoom in all the way on the like as much
as you can zoom in on an atom of the
electrons and protons and it's all
vibrating and so when you look at the
atoms that create us and nature and
animals is all a vibration
i think if we can really i call it the
divine dance where i'm like okay they're
not chaotic they're dancing and
everything is poetry in motion from like
a flower blooming like the tulip doesn't
get jealous of the rose they're both
beautiful you know and so for me it's
and i don't want to sound too spiritual
for certain people listening but like to
really be like oh it's all a divine
dance that we're in with spirit with god
with nature with each other and if you
can zoom in science have can zoom in on
the vibrational movement of an atom of
what we're created of then we could
probably figure out how to meditate and
lay in nature and ground more and so
yeah i love the movement that we're in
where science is now like proving
spirituality has yeah valid you know
right i mean i don't feel like what you
said is too woohoo at all but again
going back to the everyone's story
someone else listening might find it too
chewy or might find it even triggering
or even might want to turn it off like
someone who might be like oh this guy
right this guy using the word christian
he's not a christian i want to click it
off right or maybe even the opposite
someone who's like maybe at first maybe
their own story tells them oh this guy
is a christian i'm not a christian and
so i'm gonna turn it off right little
things like that yeah but i feel like
it's help i don't know can we talk about
like truths like you know the my truth
versus one truth versus multiple truths
at the same time i find that topic
really fascinating because i tend not to
like
the my truth thing like this is my truth
this is your truth only because i do
believe that there is like one truth for
like a lot of things but at the same
time you can also have multiple truths
for certain things so like i can listen
to this what you just said about nature
and god and and how we can connect and
how it's all so much more
infinitely detailed than we our minds
could possibly fathom right and how our
energies it's all interconnected with i
mean i believe divine purpose but
there's also
this other aspect of like someone who
might speak on a more philosophical
theological level with a spiritual text
or religion that you can kind of be like
okay there is a truth to these different
aspects i don't know do you know what
i'm saying
i can see the value in listening to to
both and like finding value from it but
also i do believe in like
single truths for a lot of things does
that even make sense yeah totally yeah i
think and like once again it's a dance
it's it's a it's a conversation it's an
emotion where um
i was i lived with monks for a while
throughout asia and throughout thailand
and japan i was like living with monks i
lived with muslims throughout the middle
east and you know growing up in america
where i wasn't really raised christian
like my parents never brought us to
church and stuff like that but i knew
what christianity was i really was like
and i was living with these these
different religions and police i was
like well the human experience is pretty
fascinating and for me to
just box it up and
you know say this is this without
evolving like the moment you think you
have it figured out is the moment you
lose
um the invitation to life and love and
and saying you have the truth you know
and so and it's a dance i know it's a
dance because there is certain truths um
and then there's certain personal truths
but to always be open and excited and
encouraged to just never stop learning
and then when you stop learning is when
you're dead like you're just done yeah
and i always tell christians this and i
have such i mean i've i've never really
fit in so for over a decade i've been
kicked out of churches and then the
spiritual community be like oh he likes
jesus in the holy spirit yeah you don't
belong here and then church would be
like oh you you you know talk about
astrology or ask questions about jesus
you're not fit in and so i've literally
never fit in for over a decade and so i
created my own kind of thing where i
started hosting events and basically
what i was to encourage you was create
what you can't find from events from
content like maybe when you started
making content you were like i can't
find a youtuber that has a family that's
plant-based and this and i can't find a
podcast that's this and so create what
you can't find so i started throwing
events that were both of those things i
started hosting um programs that were
both of those things and i was so blown
away at the amount of people that showed
up because it's not one or the other and
so basically it's a pendulum and so
there's christians over here and
everything is christian and then over
here is like you know spiritual freedom
and then i'm always just like hey
whatever you believe is okay but just
come to the middle and challenge
yourself yeah that's the only thing i
care about that's the best way to say it
yeah just like you're over here and you
don't you hate the word god you hate the
bible you treat you know and then
christians like i hate spirituality and
meditation and yoga and it's like okay
okay yeah just come to the middle and
learn and soften your heart and i would
always tell christians like if you only
believe in this thing and you have the
ultimate truth it's like swimming in a
fishbowl in the ocean where like you're
swimming you're in the fishbowl and
you're oh it's a cool fishbowl and then
the ocean is around you and you're just
staying the fishbowl and so i'm always
like yo come out of the fishbowl it's
safe you're okay you're not gonna if you
do yoga or meditate nothing's gonna
happen yeah um yeah that's fascinating
there are there are christians who are
like yoga is of the devil like you can't
even
yeah and so i've been so fortunate my
retreats and my programs i run i do it
all i do both we pray and we meditate
and do yoga and you know talk about the
holy spirit and god
um but
for me it's it's just you can't
describe it and so um someone asked me
the other day like pc they just kind of
rediscovered their spirituality practice
with god and with the holy spirit and
jesus and and they were like um bc how
do i explain this people like how do i
tell my dad that he doesn't like this
stuff how do i tell my friends and i was
like the best way to
explain this to you is imagine your
favorite song like what your favorite
song is and it gives you goosebumps it
makes you cry it like makes you you want
to dance like your favorite song can
turn your worst day into your best day
it's a miracle right it's a music and
then imagine me trying to explain my
favorite song to you without showing and
expecting you to have the same emotion
so i'm like i'm like ellen ellen there's
this song i just cried and i had
goosebumps it went doo doo doo boo boo
boo and there's this piano and saxophone
i'm like why aren't you crying and you'd
be like you'd be like you're just making
sounds you sound dumb oh i'd be like
wait you have to cry or you or you're
wrong you know what i'm saying and it's
a song that they'll never hear
but the only thing they'll see is how i
dance which is loving people and the
song i'm listening to my spiritual
experience with god is my dance aka how
i love people and one day someone said
hey what song are you dancing to because
how you love people is really powerful
and like that's it right
um you explained that amazingly i knew
you were i could tell where you're going
with that halfway through i'm like oh
because it's about who you are and how
you're acting and what's coming out yeah
that's so interesting i have a little
funny story that's kind of related to
what you're talking about um i was
raised in a really christian home and
then as i got older like i came here and
i made a friend
and she was telling me about how she was
going to this um universal worship and i
was like what is that and she was
telling me how they read these different
religious texts from all these they read
different portions from different
religious texts and like a group and
they put it on a table and i was like
well it's not just kind of taking from
the parts that you like and not using
the parts that you don't like and she's
like well yeah and i was just very i
never met someone like that so i was
just very curious and i think the word
curious and challenging yourself is
really important and at the end of the
day you can hear this and be like no i
don't agree with that that's totally
fine but for for the purpose of i think
this portion of the conversation is like
be curious and challenge yourself and so
i was like asking your questions and i'm
like
okay but this is what i hear when i see
this like what i see is like okay
there's a mango tree outside and like
that's what it is it's a mango tree and
someone goes no i think it's a banana
plant someone's like no i think it's an
avocado tree and someone's like well no
i think it's actually a papaya and then
and then i'm like so then how can you
just say it's all of it when it's just a
mango tree and she's like well i just
look at it and i just say it's beautiful
i was like what like it just totally
threw me off i did not expect her to
give that answer
and i went to bed just like
just dumbfounded
i was just cool i just had nothing to
say i was just like that is a really
interesting way to look at it and you
know i i did learn something from that
and there's a you know whether you agree
with that or not which either way right
the other day you can be like okay
maybe we don't none of us know and we're
all gonna die and be like wow none of us
really know like and maybe you'd be like
nope i don't agree with that either and
that's fine but i think just being
curious and open to listening is i don't
know half of half the fun
yeah you have to remain humble and you
have to you have to really come to every
situation yeah curious and humble and
just willing to
um you know humans with the ego we're
not really good at being wrong right
yeah we want to be right yeah and i went
into that wanting to be right like i was
like look i'm gonna prove it wrong i'm
gonna show her look how silly this is
i'm gonna be like look this is silly
like it's just a mango tree so you gotta
figure out which one it is right but she
was like oh i just look at it and i
think it's beautiful and i just did not
know what to say i was just dumb at it i
was like completely silent and i was
like okay um that's that's interesting
yeah yeah there was a pastor named judah
smith who was our pastor in la and he he
did a whole series like seven weeks of
what i wish pastors would say aka what i
wish christians would say and there was
like a whole episode on like i don't
know like just saying i don't know and i
was wrong and i'm not okay and like all
these things of like you know just
bringing in the the mental health
conversation into you know certain
doctrines and things that you know have
just become
uh politicized weaponized and and just
being humble and just being like whoa i
didn't know the that's who formed the
bible like i don't know i didn't know
that the the the meeting in uh in rome
of when they created the bible was this
these men that had an agenda you know
i'm saying like and not to attack it but
i'm just saying i i didn't know this you
know i didn't know certain things and
just always having an open heart to at
the end of the day and what you said is
how do you show up and love people
that's it that's that is the only
thing of like what is working for you
like the recipe and the formula you know
and that was actually one reason why i
was so interested in what she was saying
because she really was someone i'd met
i've never met someone like her like she
was just emanating this different type
of vibration off of her world like she's
so this and this and oh in a positive
way right and that's why i was asking
her questions so i was like what's going
on
but all that to say just like i think
just seeking after
seeking after it right and being open to
it i did not expect it to go in this
direction spiritually
yeah i mean it's all connected when it
because i feel like to be honest most of
the trauma people i work with is the
catholic church and raising being raised
christian a lot of the shame a lot of
the guilt a lot of the judgment a lot of
the limiting beliefs came from the
doctrine that they were raised in these
really intense judgmental spaces where
even like being liberated from their
sexuality being liberated from their
definitions being liberated from you
know these things that have bonded them
um and so all of it's tied together from
spiritual spirituality to um lack of
you know love or support growing up as a
kid but it's all connected and i think a
lot of people listening will probably
resonate to be like i was raised i was
raised where you know you couldn't talk
about sex you couldn't ask about
questions you couldn't do anything and
like i'm i'm saying like
i'm gonna throw them somewhere out there
but i would say 60 i would say more than
half i would say 60 maybe 70 percent of
the thousands of people i've worked with
for 14 years have had religious trauma
like more than half but there's also
people who are
who have the opposite experience where
they didn't where early is religious at
all and then they come into christianity
and have really totally found a lot of
so it's like everyone's experiences
exactly yeah i've and i've danced with
all of it you know and and yeah like my
goal is is i'm not god or jesus or you
know the holy spirit my goal is to just
help you quiet you know yourself and
really guide you through
this inner child this inner moment this
you know this disconnection from
yourself because you have all the
answers you have god within you like it
says in the bible like the spirit of god
is within every heart every single human
being has it in the kingdom within them
and so you know and jesus taught a lot
of this but it got lost in translation
and it got lost in like this separate
the separation you know but jesus was
like you can do everything i can do and
more like you're just as powerful as me
and so always coming you know letting
you know these religious people that
have um compartmentalized this control
into being liberated and just being like
yo jesus was hanging out with people who
he wasn't allowed to hang out with and
washing people's feet and doing things
and so anyway i think a lot of the
divide that happens in politics and
religion is
kind of the divide that happens in
humanity um if you really sit back and
go well if we got rid of religion and
politics we would be pretty like um
unified in certain ways and not to be i
don't want to like make people feel bad
for politics religion but just to open
up the conversation
yeah no totally and that's why i would
really love to do an episode i don't
know how to get three people together
for people
i think it would be super fascinating to
find people with like different
religious beliefs and just be like look
where's the common ground or like why do
you think the way that you do and
because i just find it fascinating it's
kind of daunting like there's just so
much information sometimes yeah those
are there's some rabbit holes you can
get down in politics and religion where
you're like oh okay i'm totally lost now
um but to always come back and that's
like from anything from the news to
media to what's wrong with the world to
what's wrong with x y and z to just be
like okay this is the only world i can
control the only world i have control
over is my internal world so if i can
only control this one i can't control
the stock market i can't control the how
much money we print i can't control this
if i can control only this one i better
figure out this one and um and that's
why i'm just always bringing people to
like yo figure out this internal world
you have
the greatest distance any person will
ever travel is only 18 inches from your
head to your heart and i always tell
that to my students in my high school
programs like you know you want to go on
the best adventure ever connect your
brain and your heart together and you'll
find adventure for the rest of your life
um
and uh yeah that's so good yeah okay so
another question pivoting a little bit
how do people identify their pain and
how do they turn it into purpose
and like when they're like learning like
why they're anxious why they're hurt and
turning it into something beautiful like
helping others how do you do that yeah
well i think we all have purpose i think
we all have a reason we're here like
there should be obviously you know um
but when you go inward and you find out
these moments that disconnected you from
joy or music or nature or your family
and you heal it you realign it you have
immense amount of compassion for all
humans
and for yourself and then you realize
that a lot of people out there don't
have
a mentor or
a person that believes in them or
supports them and so or a loving person
in their life and so you
you alchemize i haven't have you ever
booked alchemist no oh yeah no i have
heard it yeah it's a classic but you
alchemize all this pain and tragedy to
where you know you could play a victim
the rest of your life you'd be like yo
my dad didn't show up my dad didn't my
mom didn't hold me
x y and z like i have so i have a
million excuses why i can't live my
dream or love people or you know live my
million excuses
and once you heal and you go in you go
whoa i have a million things to be
grateful for i have a healthy body i've
i have x y and z you know and then you
you
transcend all of that pain into helping
others and that's literally the whole
circle of life that's every movie that
we love it's called the hero's journey
and every single movie that we love
has a tragedy has a disconnecting moment
where star wars luke skywalker's parents
died or dorothy got swept away from a
tornado like everyone has a hero's
journey they realize that they're the
hero of their own journey as well and
that the reason we love these movies and
these tv shows is it connects to us and
so we come back home in the hero's
journey joseph campbell created this
whole algorithm and formula around it um
is really coming back to like oh now i
get to live my life for other people so
i never had x y and z in high school so
i became the best i don't wanna cuss but
the best mentor i could ever become like
i loved these kids like i wish i loved
myself in high school so what i did is i
time traveled so basically when you go
into the quantum healing of life and
love is you time travel to where i was
crying myself to sleep in high school i
was so lonely i was so depressed i never
fit in no one ever complimented how i
looked and encouraged me on my brain or
like my lack of whatever you know just
encouraged me yeah so what i do is i go
into high schools and i do that for that
these kids i love them and support them
encourage them build relationships and
what i'm doing is i'm time traveling so
i can help my high school self yeah
you're healing from what you didn't get
yeah you can change the past and
the brain i think you can truly change
the past people say you can't change the
past oh you can you can go into the
quantum healing of like now a 15 year
old kid doesn't have to cry himself to
sleep or take his life or take
medication because he was loved because
i wasn't loved and so like i could play
the victim i wasn't loved i never fit in
or i could play you know to support in
someone's life and
yeah yeah there's a difference between
being a victim to an experience
something that happened to you versus
living in victimhood yeah and living in
victimhood state your whole life like
saying i can't do this because of this
this and this and xyz this is there's a
big difference if you look at someone
who's living in victimhood versus a
victor mentality and what the outcome is
in their life because different traumas
are going to shape you and are going to
happen but how you respond to them is
what matters the most yeah yeah we're
not a victim to because alcohols and
runs in the family we're victim to the
trauma of why alcohol is in resident
family you know even when kids hear that
they're bad at school or they've
scientifically proven that when a kid
hears the parents went oh yeah he's
really shy or he's really sad the chem
so the reason why there's chemical
imbalances in our brain from add to
anything they've signs they've proven
that it's because the story we're
telling ourselves so literally the
chemical imbalance isn't from um the
chemistry of our
ancestors it's because
of what we're being told that we're
creating our own reality yeah and that's
why what i was saying before about how
huge a responsibility it is when you're
raising kids to work on yourself because
you're projecting all your past traumas
on your kids with the little things that
you say you don't even realize it
yeah yeah and so yeah the ongoing
healing journey when no one reaches the
ultimate you know consciousness nirvana
like you know if you did then yeah
you're missing out on just being human
again and so be human like go through
your heartbreak with the relationships
go through your your morning for your
dad being you know passing away and go
through these things um but always come
back to to i can help someone now i can
i can really uh i'm a soul experiencing
a human not a human experiencing you
know this emptiness so do you kind of
feel like based on what you're saying
that with your traumas a way to heal is
to go and help those that are
potentially experiencing that same
trauma you had or do you heal yourself
first and then go help them so that's a
beautiful question so so there's this
there's this thing that goes around a
lot that i always challenge people on
but people like you can't pour from an
empty cup so everyone says you can't
pour focus on yourself first feed
yourself first and i believe that i
support that if you believe that i love
you
and i would say not but but and i think
helping people is what fills your cup
and so so many people like okay when i
find my wife then i'll volunteer for
kids when i get my money then i'll
donate to charities i think purpose is
when you help people and you donate
before you have all your [ __ ] figured
out your life becomes magnetically in
line with just love and life to where
like i was never looking for a wife i
was living in my lane in my life and
magnetically she came to me in this
beautiful way and i was never looking
for money money was never the goal but
it came to me from living in this
alignment and so i showed up with an
empty cup
um
because i you
look at the richest people look at the
most fittest like ask the richest person
that you know hey are you extremely
happy all the time they're like hell no
ask the fittest person that you know hey
do you feel sexy all the time they're
like hell no you know i'm saying ask the
model that you know do you feel gorgeous
all the time all of them are saying no
so basically what we've learned is the
algorithm we've been given the formula
of get your money first get your lover
first and get your house first and get
yourself first isn't working and so i
think
offering another option of like hey find
ways to heal yourself and heal people
and support people and i think the money
will come i think the lover will come i
think
the friendships will come yes i totally
agree with that i think there's kind of
like a duality to that topic of you
can't pour from an empty cup because you
know on a micro level like on a
day-to-day basis if i'm not taking care
of myself i'm like i'm going to become a
cranky mom you know like i need to i
need to have 20 minutes to myself you
know something for myself every day i
need to feed myself well i need to make
myself a priority in that aspect in
order for me to be my best self to my
kids and to my husband and everything
like that i need to take time with my
friends but on this other macro level
it's almost like a bigger macro level
like you're the purpose that you're
living the day to day things
maybe not day to day but the bigger
level is what i can see what you're
saying about not needing to get
everything together first in order for
you to do anything to help others
exactly yeah so i feel like it's kind of
like both
yeah i mean for me it's just it's
offering another idea yeah but it's a
really good point because there's this
there's off there's actually this um
uh
really common popular thing right now
that's like you know cut toxic people
out of your life like anyone who's like
not you know this perfect uplifting
friend basically someone who's giving
you everything you want all the time or
isn't exactly making you feel greatest
when you're around them cut them out of
your life and i see the purpose in
something like that because you know if
you if you boundaries right healthy
boundaries with people there are certain
boundaries that you have to have with
you know i cannot have that
going on right but then there's also
this other idea that i had watched this
video by my actually my friend dr gemini
i had her on the podcast her husband
made this video about how we would never
say that with like anything else in the
world if like our governments were like
all the rich people stop helping the
poor people all those people who are
doing well mentally stop helping those
who aren't mentally well but we do that
with our own lives like right now it's
just so popular on social media and it
gives an excuse to list just not help
others or to not um be there for others
because of the sake of your own
right like easiness and comfort in your
life and so there's kind of a boundary
right like there's kind of a balance i
mean totally yeah and that's a lot of
what i talk about in my programs too
because um
there's a lot of spiritual people who
are you know woke and tapped in and so
you know smart online but then they you
go home with their families and they're
triggered and they're yelling at their
mom and they're talking [ __ ] about their
brother and you're just like wait
that and i always say like
you the full circle of your healing
journey is you go home and you alchemize
the relationship with your family and i
thought i was so
tapped in because i was loving people
and changing people's lives and and then
i would go home and be triggered by my
sister my mom my dad and i was like oh
i'm just a bullshitter i'm just like and
boundaries i get boundaries like if your
family's attacking you i get it but like
abuse and like holy [ __ ]
and
you'll know when someone when someone's
in a romantic relationship or with their
family you'll know how much work they've
done and i just always joke with like
these spiritual gurus because you know
so many people can be so inspiring and
in line but then you see them in their
romantic partner and they're like
cussing at their person and and you know
i'm just saying it's a joke but but
basically
you know
the full circle your journey is going
where your traumas were birthed where
they came from why is your sister and
brother so triggering why is why can you
tap into this alignment and then you're
you know the zen and chain you know
inspire people on a podcast but then
your mom and dad say something and
you're just triggered
i'm like yo go heal that and you'll see
how much healing you need to do so for
instance my sister this i have a
personal story but you know a year ago a
year and a half ago if you told
i couldn't spend more than 30 seconds
with my sister it's just really intense
energy super opposing
super
high level kind of energy and
then i'm leading a retreat last year and
at my retreat i'm about to host a
workshop on vulnerability and i get a
text that my sister is like about to try
to take her life like really intense
situation and i get really emotional
and then uh
yeah sorry don't be sorry
yeah so then for me i'm like oh man like
what am i doing like my head so far my
ass that like i you know i'm gonna miss
the point of all of it
and so
i moved back home with to denver just to
you know love on my sister and and it
wasn't i needed to change my sister i
needed to change my lens on my sister
[Music]
sorry oh my god i totally cried on my
last one
and i'm crying i cry as soon as i hear
as soon as i see someone else crying i
cry the lens on my mom the lens on my
dad the lens on my sister that's what
needed to change not them and so we
think so much like okay i can i'll love
my mom and my sister and my dad when
they change that's not how love works
and so yeah i changed the lens on how i
see my sister and i couldn't spend 30
seconds with her you know a year and a
half ago and now we work out together
i'll go to i'll go over her on saturday
to her house and
like clean her house with her and and
that's a miracle to me because i can
love people who love me that's really
that's easy freaking easy but to love
someone who's extremely challenging is
the ultimate epitome of love
unconditional love that's what love is
it's the highest frequency of of
unconditional so for me it was the
ultimate challenge and so um i had to
take my head on my ass and be like all
right let's see if you can preach what
you or live while you preach so now
we're great friends we hang out all the
time we work out together and she hasn't
changed well she's she's healthier now
but she isn't nothing about her has
changed i had to change the lens yeah
and so
anyway i just always want to encourage
people to you know it is boundaries i
get it like i know if you have abusive
verbally or physically family members or
people in your relationship like have
boundaries but also
figure out your triggers point to your
freedom and so what triggers you from
your mom your dad your sister actually
hold the keys to your heart um into your
liberation and so yeah to always
encourage people to go inward thanks for
sharing that that's like i feel very
honored that you got to share that that
you were willing to share that and thank
you for that story because it's a
perfect example of how often
relationships based on this story that
we're told on social it mainly seems
like i'm seeing it on social media of
just cut toxic people out of your life
which again to reiterate of course there
are boundaries are certain situations
that are essential and
necessary um but a lot of times i feel
like that kind of message is used as a
crutch to be like look anytime i'm
uncomfortable anytime i feel like maybe
i go through a challenging experience
with a friend or someone
in my life um for my own sake for my own
mental health i need to cut that person
out of my life but is that really the
answer or is actually searching in your
soul and be like where can i learn from
the situation and how can we come
together and actually heal from whatever
happened is that the answer you know and
maybe you don't have to be best friends
with the person but healing from that
experience as opposed to just cutting
someone out of your life in the name of
mental health right but then there's
also the understanding of like some
people really are struggling mentally
and some people can't handle as much as
maybe the next person so maybe one
person can be like i don't understand
like why can't we just have a
conversation whereas the next person
truly is struggling like with their
mental health in a way that maybe the
other person will never understand so
just trying to understand that other
person yeah totally yeah it's even same
with medication right so like i get the
medication you know when you're trying
to show up to work or school you need
something to help with the with what
you're going through but
it's not the answer right so it's just
like it's it's it's there's something
deeper going in you know where it's like
it helps you get above water so you can
function in a culture in a society but
to really it's like a band-aid over a
really deep wound and so the trauma is
the wound and and sometimes i'm not all
situation but a lot of times the pharma
medication can just be a band-aid and
this wound still bleeding but the
band-aid's holding it back but that's
because you don't have time or resources
or capacity to figure the wound out
and so yeah it definitely comes back to
always just you know yourself and and um
being sovereign within yourself like you
said like being free and liberated to um
not have to use words like boundaries or
i mean yeah you can use those words
every i mean i don't know is this like
everyone has their own walk it's the
gray totally it's the gray of just like
yeah have awareness but but also have
vulnerability of um just a community of
people who you can talk to about these
things whether you know you're
questioning your church and your beliefs
and your communities like oh those are
great questions i've had those too and
the reason i share this situation with
my sister is because maybe someone's
like oh i'm going through that too like
i can't i can't get on the same page as
my brother and sister so i push them
away forever and then you get to your
death bed or they get to their death bed
and you're like whoa what a waste of an
opportunity and like my dad and i had
like friction but when he passed away
from cancer you know so many things went
through like whoa i
missed the ball on that you know and so
um and when healing that and so
yeah just really encouraging people man
this life is so beautiful and wild and
precious and to to write someone off of
your family members because what they
voted for or they believe politically or
religiously is just like a loss we're
just like oh man that's why the news can
be is mostly so toxic because it's so
divisive on both sides i feel like and
it just ends up it pits everybody
against each other
so do you feel like with what happened
with your dad that you had to even heal
from those feelings of missing out oh
totally yeah and that's what i wanna i
want everyone even people have tough
relationships with parents i'm like yo i
know it's hard i know they've called you
names i know they've wronged you but try
your best because there's something to
be learned in it and there's something
that when they pass away you will always
hold this like level if you don't do it
this level of like oh my god i could
have just forgave him you know like he
i'm not thinking with my mad dad but my
god it was just ten thousand dollars
like or five thousand two thousand
dollars or it was just this thing he
said to me when he was mad once like you
know it's like that was so small like i
could have forgave that we could have
like he could have held my grandkids you
know there's so much that we just hold
on to this resentment because of money
or you know broken people and uh i think
everyone has a chance to to find that
revival and that healing yeah i love
that yeah so do you feel like
if we're gonna talk about social media
then like what are the toxic things that
you see happening based on all these
things we've talked about with like
judgment and divisiveness like
how do people move from there because it
is very easy for us to
or for a lot of people to get quick to
you know judge other people and maybe
criticize or say you need to be doing it
this way and that way or this person's
back is of this the call out culture all
that stuff like where where do we go
from here like as a collective
yeah well i think we go inward i think
we continue to heal and go inward and
then realize that anyone that's
attacking us is just hurting like
they're just hurting and they have
enough time in their day to spend 30
seconds on a comment to hate someone you
actually have compassion for them like
dang they must really be going through
it to not only just be going through it
but to spend time attacking someone
when you could spend that time doing so
much for people or the world or yourself
or hiking you know what i'm saying and
so just having that compassion and
staying in your lane i've had haters
since day one since you know i was
traveling the world helping communities
before social media was a thing i was
working with high school kids before
social media was a thing so it became
like a uh
byproduct of what i was doing um and
then haters came you know but you know
your truth you know who you are and what
you're doing and so it's like a bummer
some days but i think to just always
have compassion for those people and
move on you know like i've had dms and
people try to attack me and cancel me
for working with inner city kids to
helping build an orphanage in uganda to
uh picking a flower or feeding a
homeless person like there's nothing you
can do in our culture now that's not
going to trigger someone
so so just it really is not you probably
have triggered so many people yeah you
can hand a homeless person food and you
know people will say that why that's
wrong oh you did it right yeah you can
pick a flower and someone says wrong so
so just always staying true and
committed and um you know using social
media as a byproduct of what you're
doing you know you're already being an
amazing mother and conscious con
consumer in your life and now social
media has been a byproduct of that so
many young people like i want to be a
youtuber i want to be an instagram i'm
like that's not a thing that doesn't
exist like find something you're
passionate about enjoy it get really
good at if it's rock climbing if it's
gardening if it's traveling and then
have social media be the byproduct of it
but right now this generation's coming
up thinking that you were just handed
these cookbooks and these vegan recipes
and these kids you know and people think
i'm handed this opportunity of like
talking about this but 14 years of
working with thousands high school kids
and young adults in trauma work yeah i
don't have a phd in front of my name but
what is i mean and i do appreciate
doctors and phds i do appreciate that
and i
there's something this experiential
learning of if i've worked with
thousands of people on their trauma for
14 years yeah i'm not a doctor i'm not
going to say i'm a doctor i'm not going
to prescribe medicine but i understand
it pretty well you know you're not a
nutri dietitian but you understand
food really well yeah um so yeah i i
don't know what was the question
i don't remember
um but a lot but there's just so much to
say about it i think that a lot of times
like you said we're quick to judge
anything right um there's gonna be
opinions no matter what about anything
that you do you mentioned the picking a
flower thing and there's also the
understanding that hey maybe there's
certain things i haven't considered like
the toms thing i thought have you ever
heard about how people have criticisms
towards how that's actually affected um
the people living in those communities
that used to make shoes that have now
been priced out of a job to even make
shoes so that's an interesting component
so sometimes it's like it's it's always
interesting to listen right and be like
okay where what could i be missing right
but then there's also the factor of like
looking in within your own heart if
you're feeling compelled to criticize
others and just be like look they're
doing it wrong they should have been
doing it this way and this way to look
inward and also be like hey wait what
what could i be doing yeah because that
is um something that we had talked about
last night that i had seen someone say
this quote that like you'll never be
criticized by someone who's doing more
than you yeah and that is i mean without
a doubt that has been my experience
whoever's doing more than me like
they're too busy
to criticize me they're too busy
they don't have time to come and tell me
how i'm doing it wrong they're just
going out and doing what they think is
right they're going out and doing what
they think is going to make a difference
and what they think is the most helpful
and if you're sitting behind a screen
and you're like typing
this person around this person's doing
it around this is you know there's a
difference between having like
interesting conversations where you're
curious or you're challenging in an
interesting way as opposed to just
criticism this person's doing it wrong
yeah
yeah it's definitely um
yeah that's it that's it's all of that
it's definitely heartbreaking to see
yeah the social media play such a big
role in just the divisiveness and the
separation but coming down to i was
telling you last night too like you know
i've had so many so many things like
that in the last 10 years but being like
hey if you're not at the table actually
changing the world or making a
difference it's hard to listen to you
because you're not trying you know and i
would rather fail like tom's i would you
know it i would rather fail
something trying to help people than do
nothing you know so tom's had its like
heart behind the idea was like oh this
is the opportunity to help people and
then found out there were certain
situations but it helped a lot of people
and yes it might have made mistakes
along the way but you know why don't we
why don't we care when nike or apple use
child labor for their products like we
don't care when like i know like you buy
nike and apple without a fling blind eye
but they use child labor and all this
stuff oh my gosh it's so true it's like
a lot of times it's like all the things
that aren't trying to help anyone
there's no criticisms for no matter how
much detriment or harm they're doing but
anyone who's trying to help help someone
it's like you're doing it wrong this
one's not as good as this like that's
too true yeah the verbage everything but
there's also something sorry go ahead
the verbiage no yeah i think yeah just
you know i always come to like yo i you
know i when i went to inner city you
know work with inner city kids and live
in the communities and help as much as i
could i would you know there's a quote
that an african-american mentor mind
said and he said you can't solve a
problem you don't understand and you
can't understand from a distance and so
every every conversation i went into and
every movement i've ever learned about i
had to get close to it to understand it
and and to always just just have that
like awareness to be like yo you gotta
like yeah you said build bridges
lean in and ask questions and and try to
understand and and i like i always tell
people like yo i don't have a i don't
have a phd in trauma work
um but but i i've i learned by doing and
and if i've made a mistake in certain
situations um you know it's it's not uh
as long as it's not an intense mistake
you know i'm not prescribing medication
but i'm not telling people not to do
medication but i you know i'm doing work
that is anything anything when you're
giving back to somewhere but yeah
non-profits philanthropy helping people
you do one thing and it's you're done
you know but it is also
sorry i got water in my throat
it is also helpful to be able to be
humble enough to open and hear when
there is something that you can
change right so with toms i wonder what
happened with them because they could
potentially be like oh we didn't realize
this was happening maybe we can you know
support these workers in these areas and
actually have them make the shoes and we
support them that way with our dollars
so these kids are still getting the
shoes but we're supporting the i don't
know it was just it's just nothing they
didn't do that yeah did they start doing
that so essentially they took that that
conscious criticism that feedback and
and learned from it and that's beautiful
too there's that balance yeah yeah i
made a mistake i was wrong just like
those things our ego hates saying you
know i'm sorry yeah our ego is like
never um our pride is like never like
even when you're in an argument with
your husband or with your mom and just
your pride and your ego is just like
this hard pill to swallow and you're
like man i'm sorry i was really rude i
made a mistake and i was wrong like you
know and just like the beautifulness of
those words um that vulnerability is
just incredible even with your kids
someday you know you're gonna make
mistakes and say the wrong things and
they're gonna ask questions and i love
all the questions elvis asks um
but yeah he's a really good question oh
my gosh he asked so many amazing
questions people are like oh my gosh
this kid everything yeah um he's very
curious yeah and then and you know and
like you said your boundaries you're
doing you're you know and you have these
platforms which is great but your number
one focus a good wife a good um mother
and that's your number one priority
right now and this is all beautiful and
a byproduct but you know just and then
when your kids grow up you'll transition
to another thing so everything in life
is seasons and chapters and they don't
define you you know and so i always want
people to just like separate from
you know these definitions to we're so
much more than just x y and z but this
is the season of your life right now as
you're committed and focused to those
things yeah um and they'll grow and
evolve and shift and uh
yeah that's the part of life yeah
because at the end of the day i am a
mother and a wife first and that's
what's the most important to me and what
you said about
apologizing is such an important part of
parenting and respectful parenting and
just being that example to your kids too
because when you're willing to say sorry
when you've made a mistake
they're gonna be willing to say sorry
when they've made a mistake you know if
mom can't even do it why would i do it
yeah right because we all make mistakes
yeah oh and kids watch way more than
they listen yeah they always watch their
parents way more and so
yeah that's so important and the way you
love your kids now is going to overflow
into where they love their teammates and
their classmates and their friends and
it's all part of the intrinsic like
overflow of of life yeah and so even my
sister loving her where you know in her
position now she's telling me stories
where she's loving her employees more
because she's feeling sick it's all
about the neurosystem of the trauma but
sh when we're in fight or flight mode we
don't feel safe and so we're you know
when you see one driving and they're
flipping people off and come people off
and they're in that fight or flight mode
but now my sister feels safe and and
hopefully seen and supported to where
now she her shoulders are dropped she's
not in fight or flight mode of survival
and now she's like oh my gosh my
employee friend is having a tough day i
should probably go ask her how she's
doing you know what i'm saying so it all
ripple effects into everywhere you can
notice other people so much more when
you're not caught up within yourself and
dealing with your own crap and your own
trauma because if i'm ever going through
something that's just really affecting
my mental wellness and it's just it
takes over your whole day and that's all
you can see and suddenly you can find
yourself snapping at your kids or you're
not even noticing anything around you
because you're just so caught up in your
own problems in your brain and sometimes
it's not even justified sometimes it's
like the stories you tell yourself being
more important than it actually is and
that's why it's so helpful then like
it's so helpful for me to have andrew
because he is like this calming very
strong presence for me that if i ever
let something like get to me
he's like that bringing down to reality
maybe not the way that i always like i
might be like oh gosh i wish you said
that different or i can't listen to you
right now but at the end of the day he's
right and he'll be like look that does
not matter like like look at around you
like open your eyes
and see what is actually in front of you
and you'll see that that's actually like
the problem you have in your head is not
actually what you're making it out to be
yeah and that's why breath work
meditation yoga like all these things
are like you can't think your way out of
these problems you can't you know the
more we spend up here the more dangerous
it gets it's like a snowball and the
second you lay in nature and you
literally breathe for like if no one's
ever heard of breath work on this
podcast look it up it's unbelievable um
but what they've discovered in breath
work is you re-regulate your system and
you get out of your head into your body
and then you feel safe and you feel sort
of like oh my gosh i was thinking i was
holding that much it was like grabbing
glass you were just cutting yourself
more and bleeding and so
um i love that you know these therapists
these doctors are just encouraging you
know grounding outside laying on the
ground and breathing
um and uh
yeah it's it's so crucial but we're all
human so definitely there's there's hum
you can be human um yeah we're gonna be
humans yeah we're gonna be humans and i
still yeah i'm not like there yet you
know but i i i you get resources and
tools what i tell my my participants in
my programs my retreats is you know life
never gets easier you just get stronger
and not like a stronger muscle weight
stronger vulnerable way stronger
awareness and so life you're not going
to have a million dollars or a million
followers and then you're like oh it's
all easy now it's like no that's usually
opposite um but you want a million
followers and a million dollars so you
have freedom and most people who have
those things have the opposite of
freedom most the time you know when it's
done unyoked like on a poor foundation
and so just being like no what you want
is just inner peace of needings a lover
you know even like issa my my wife my
partner um
she is her own sovereign person and and
there's no jealousy in our relationship
there's no insecurities because we know
how sovereign we are and that we don't
belong to each other and i don't love
this this is kind of be kind of
triggering i've never said this publicly
yet but i was meditating and praying the
other day and my what issa taught me my
wife was i had to love people deeper and
then my kid taught me how to love people
deeper and so like i don't love my wife
and kid i would say more than anyone
else i literally try my best to
unconditionally love everyone but what
they invited me into is a deeper
understanding of love and so i don't my
you know there's like a we separate
people of like i love my kids and my
wife more and it's like well no they've
taught you how to love deeper and so you
can love people better
and the end goal is to become better at
loving people and so if a job can do
that or money can do that or a lover or
kids
then that's beautiful too but um i was
like writing in my journal i was like
yeah i don't love
phoenix or isa more i just
they've taught me how to love deeper um
that's interesting i've never considered
that yeah i was super interested i was
like i don't know if i could say that
publicly but we'll see
um you can say anything you want yeah i
know i know uh but yeah just that's the
goal is really you know and you don't go
to a doctor if you're not sick so i'm
never gonna preach to people you know
like i think people like pastors will
get on the sidewalk and preach and it's
like i'm never going to preach people
about trauma or love or heart work if
you're not going to go to a doctor if
you're not sick so i'm going to do what
i got to do and if people are ready to
do the work whether you're 40 years old
or 20 years old we'll dance but like i
never want to be a preacher or a leader
you know i think for me the definition
of a leader is a servant and so i'm here
to serve people not lead people and i
really want to just help them and even
people on my programs like hey can i
can't afford this retreat or this
mastermind should i do it or i'm like yo
if you don't feel
i'm never going to convince someone or
market someone selling like you're
you're a vegan book like you you have to
do like the marketing a little bit but
you're not going to sit there and be
like buy the book it'll change your life
you know like that just sounds
inauthentic and so i never sell my
programs i never do network market i
never do marketing with it i'm just like
this is it and if you're 40 and you're a
single dad and if you're 20 and a
college year student you're all welcome
and we can all talk about these things
um so yeah that's awesome yeah i was
thinking about the things that you said
that help like ground you
and heal your heart and i go back to
like my mind change sessions with my
friend heather because i'll at the
beginning of a session and during it
it like brings you to this place where
you're in the heightened you feel those
traumas the most you go to that place
where you remember it and you feel it
and it's really hard because then you
feel it at its height and then by the
end of it when you walk away like the
days after i'm like wow i don't i don't
feel that anymore why do i not feel that
intensity in my brain that i did before
yeah that intensity where it felt like
something this was seriously wrong this
is a serious problem this is huge huge
huge the way that i felt it before i
don't feel that anymore so that's really
interesting i mean the greatest example
is the movie inside out the kids movie i
love that and they they like made a
circle for sadness and they're like all
right circle their sadness don't leave
the circle and she's like okay like
they're like sadness just stay away
today and they realize i don't want to
spoil the movie for anyone yeah
hopefully you've all seen it it's
amazing movie but they realized sadness
was the key was the secret key the
portal that it's okay to feel it and
actually you have to go through that
portal to
um heal yeah you have to feel it yeah
sadness is okay and right now in the
western world we're literally raising a
generation of like oh you're sad boom oh
you're anorexic boom here's a pill oh
you're um
your add here's a pill you know we're
not asking the diet like even my mom
went to the doctor the other day and i
was so sad she went to a doctor an
actual doctor and she was like i have
heartburn and he's like oh take these
pills and
and good luck and i was like well did he
tell you about the pills and she's like
no i was like did he ask about your diet
did he like no i was like he didn't ask
what you're eating or how long to take
the pills for what's inside the pills
like what's the chemical so i looked up
the pills and ended up being bad for her
if you take it longer than a week so
anyway i was just like so heartbroken
and so um yeah it's okay to be sad like
it's like depression is an umbrella to a
lot of emotions that we just need to
feel
and and so to encourage people it's okay
to be angry angry is an okay thing like
anger is okay if you need to punch it
out punching bag or or release this
energy like sadness and anger are okay
and so um i think people feel broken if
they feel too sad or too angry um and we
just need to go back to
like love love is the only thing that
transforms someone we our minds want to
change people you know when people like
not you but like some vegans are like
everyone was plant-based i wish everyone
was christian i wish everyone was this
our mind and ego wants to change people
but the only thing that's ever changed
anyone is love it transforms people from
the inside out not like when my mom's
vegan then i'll love her or when
someone's christian then i'll love them
that's outside in but with love you know
going to my sister and being like yo i'm
gonna love you regardless you know
has taught me a lot so totally and often
like for a lot of people when they first
become vegan or they watch a documentary
or they listen to a speech stuff you
might think i gotta tell everybody
everybody needs to why is nobody else
caring and you're like what the heck
nobody cares what the heck and you feel
like you gotta change people but then
over time you realize i just gotta be me
and like just
live the life that feels like the
example and then it really does come
that way just being the example because
nobody likes to be told what to do no
one but when you mention the thing about
um emotions and not um people feeling
like they can't be sad or angry it made
me think back to what you said about
the 30 year old men
the the boys and the 30 year old men
bodies because often times not always
but more often boys are kind of taught
to shove their emotions down and i think
it is changing with this like uprising
of respectful parenting positive
parenting that we see now but i don't
think it's as big as it definitely could
be it's understanding that like you know
boys need to be able to
express their emotions and their sadness
and their feelings just as much as girls
do and to not like separate the two as
like only a real boy or a strong man
would would wouldn't cry you know type
thing and that stuff it makes total
sense why we have so many broken men
growing up because girls are more likely
to be accepted and loved and held when
they're feeling sad it's more accepted
right for a girl not always but that's
just what i've seen and for boys it's
kind of like shove it down don't cry
don't feel the sad feeling so no wonder
when you're an adult you don't know how
to handle your emotions and you just
want to yell at someone when you're
actually just feeling sad you just need
to be sad for a little bit with your
friend or your partner yeah i mean one
in three suicides adults is men like men
are you know 70 more chance to take
their life because of that like women
you know and i mean there's so much we
can talk about you know women
show their emotions and have their own
feminine cycles and moon cycles and you
know release this energy and then yeah
men have you know this this this energy
with the feminine where it's like more
of an attacking thing or an alpha thing
or you know there's like this men work
doing right and even right now there's
probably 78 women listening to this
right yeah whenever i get like a man
that comes up to me or says like hey
you're that podcaster i'm like that's
awesome
yeah i like grab them when i when i hear
people saying that i'm like oh my you're
so amazing you don't even know and so
yeah i've been in this work for so long
it's now shifting so basically what i
was telling lauren the other day was um
men only evolved to where women put the
bar right so you know women are like
money muscles and success you know so
men are like oh that's where i got to
get to and right now women are having
their own liberation and sovereignness
and awakeness to where now men are like
whoa i have to read these books breath
work and meditate and and okay all you
know so it's now happening right now
which is really exciting to see um it's
still slow but you know you just have to
be patient with it and um and just
encourage every emotion every uh like
literally in our next program our online
program we have a 40 year old
entrepreneur guy doing it and he's never
really talked about these things and i'm
like just geeking out every time i talk
to him i'm like oh my god i'm so excited
like
dude congrats like oh to be 40 year old
man and to be like well i need to do the
work i need to forgive my mom or
whatever it is yeah because you a lot of
times you think oh they're fine on this
surface level but you really don't know
what's going on inside a lot of the
times with um grown men oh my goodness
yeah and you just ask certain questions
and and uh even my mentor he is wrote
two new york best time selling books
tommy spaulding and he teaches ceos of
fortune 500 companies how to love their
employees better like literally like how
to know them by name how to know their
family's names like how to love better
and so um yeah it's been beautiful to
watch that journey and then a lot of
those ceos kids come to our programs and
so i've received phone calls from the
founder of groupon being like hey you
changed my daughter's life i want to fly
you to chicago and host you because she
now has emotion and passion and purpose
and i'm like oh cool so it's cool to see
like
ceos of fortune 500 companies like the
pinnacle of it is now learning to love
better is the dream and that's where
hopefully money and conscious capitalism
come into play and that's where more
change real change actually happens
totally and you mentioned something
about like the words that you put to
like what you're looking
something about that about looking to
feel and it made me think back to a mind
change session i did with heather and i
said something about maybe i need
thicker skin and she's like but is that
really what you want do you really want
thicker skin in all situations or or is
it that you need that you need something
else and that was interesting to me just
about the wording that i was thinking
this is what i need i just need to have
thicker skin i need you know that type
of thing but really it was more about
like letting down the boundaries opening
up and
a lot it was so much more meaningful
than just thicker skin and so that just
also makes me think about the the men
boys and the men's body thing totally
yeah i know and i have such a you know
heart and compassion for for men but
such a celebration for the ones doing
the work and
and the the balance the dance between
the you know men have feminine energy
and features
we came from a feminine energy like we
came through the portal of our mom's
womb and legs um into this world and so
we're extremely connected to the
feminine we just
have been so hurt and you know
disappointed maybe now we're like
men back in the day were protectors of
the tribes and women and now we're the
predators like we've literally lost
purpose as men and so we've lost now
protecting women to now we prey on women
like we're the dangerous part now so you
know having tons of empathy and
compassion like never judgmental but but
to to really like call men up into this
like divine masculine not the alpha and
the betas like there's like these men
like you don't don't date a beta man
it's like okay you're already you're
already using the wrong termite but
divine masculine that is gone through
into the feminine energy into their
mother into their sister into the
compassionate holding space um for like
oh she's pmsing or she's dramatic and
it's like
dude like listen you know listen um but
yeah that could be a whole episode oh i
know trust me i mean yeah we could
there's so many fun ways we can go with
this uh but
um yeah it's been obviously amazing this
is i hope you know everyone listening i
hope i hope there's a lot of men out
there listening and
and uh just yeah felt a little bit of
hope and light totally i mean there's a
couple more things i think would be fun
no totally i'm just encouraging everyone
if you're still listening i love you
you're amazing totally i'm thankful for
anybody who listens like this far into
the episodes or what listens to the
whole thing it's celebrate yourself
right now so funny if you're listening
um so what let's talk a little bit about
jealousy and like where does it come
from what how can you turn it into
something beautiful
yeah jealousy is a tough one um
i think where i get most heartbroken is
people use this scripture that god is a
jealous god you know um and we've turned
that into country songs and like rap
songs um but jealousy is is not it's not
sustainable it is not um
it is it doesn't work in the algorithm
of loving people um because you know
you're not going to get jealous
it's basically stemming from an
insecurity right so if your son goes and
jumps on your dad the dad and goes i
love you daddy you're the best parent
you're the best dad you know you're
gonna hopefully if you're healed you're
gonna be like oh that's amazing that my
son loves my dad his dad that much or if
you're really unhealed and insecure
you'd be like oh my i gotta i gotta buy
him something i got to uh i gotta
reclaim this first position parent you
know and it happens in our families it
happens with our kids it happens with
our friends and then it happens with our
romantic life and then so many
relationships end because we weren't
we weren't healed enough to know that
it's okay if my partner has guy friends
and loves them and compliments their
looks you know what i'm saying like you
and so
it just limits us a lot of the time to
friendships and um
yeah it's just a it just goes back to
the what's going on inside your heart in
your head
that is making you insecure that your
kid can't compliment the dad or your
wife or his husband can't go grab coffee
with you know another man or woman
what about jealousy for some for
something that you don't have oh yeah
that's comparison
yeah so jealousy uh there's a different
studies on this too and spiritual side
of it but basically it is when you're
jealous of someone that has something
it's because you know you're worth it
your soul knows that you also deserve a
beautiful house in hawaii with these
kids and this amazing loving husband
but your ego and your trauma is
attacking it because your ego and your
trauma is scared of that kind of love
and so um yeah jealousy on that level is
very divisive when it's like oh my god
bc has a beautiful wife and a healthy
you know i'm so jealous of that and it's
like no you deserve it and you're worthy
of it and you're worthy of someone who
adores you and loves you and you're
worthy of a kid and a job that is
amazing for you like you're so worthy of
it and we're not different we're not
separate from these people that look up
to us or you know want a certain asp and
they're hard they people also you know
people don't look at how hard our life
is and the back end on different things
um it's just a different kind of heart
um and so yeah jealousy really stems
from i know i'm worthy of it and i
deserve it um whether you want to be a
coach or a vegan chef or a vegan
cookbook you know or an author um
but we're just really mad and sad that
uh we don't have it and we're not
willing to do the work to get it
i think yeah i think that um jealousy
that that whole phrase jealousy is a
thief of joy is so true and it kind of
reminds me of the
um
being a victim to something versus
victimhood living in victimhood as well
it's a similar type of thing if you're
living in this state of jealousy of
looking at somebody else like i could
look at someone else and what they have
and be like oh god it's so not fair that
they have that or this or that it's and
be jealous about it and compare but
really if you turn that into something
that's inspirational and be inspired by
it be like what are they doing that i
can do
to have a piece of that or to do that
because it's so it's unlimited like the
type of because success is is all
relative it's not just money it's not
just looks it's not just family like
success is what you feel success is and
there's no limitation to it there's no
there's no this pot or pool of like
certain people can have it certain
people cannot that's just not how it
works and so realizing that and being
inspired by others and what you can do
to take action in your own life as
opposed to sitting back and be like i
could never be this and that with that
self-deprecating talk that negative talk
that you give yourself like that's only
going to make things worse in your life
as opposed to being inspired by others
yeah when you heal jealousy becomes
possibility and so basically what you're
jealous of is what you desire but then
someone did it so that means you can do
it you know i'm saying like like you
have four kids on this land in hawaii
and before that didn't exist maybe you
know i'm using a metaphor but like maybe
that didn't exist in someone's psyche
maybe that was someone's dream and goal
to be plant-based and live off the lane
all this stuff and then they see it and
they have two options they can either go
oh my god she's doing it that means i
can do it or oh my god that's that's
she cheated or something like that you
know and so always coming back success
keeps count and so
success is an energetic vibration it's
like a person where it watches you and
it watches and it only wants to be
around where it's celebrated and so if
you can't celebrate your friend's
success or your stranger's success then
success won't want to hang out with you
and so like success is like now i'm not
gonna hang out with you you're like
dogging out you're not gonna buy your
friend's t-shirt or your friend's
product or you know support this mother
um then i'm not going to hang out with
you and so we literally opposite
magnetic repel you repel it yeah um and
they've proven this too with science
that we are magnetic fields like we
actually draw in this is the positive um
like a battery and this is the negative
and so we draw in from the ground we
draw on from our experiences and then we
emit a frequency that that comes to us
of whatever we're creating and so and
that's science now like that's not even
woo anymore but um
yeah jealousy is just being thankful
that someone else did it so you can do
it too yeah or maybe you find
inspiration from a certain aspect of it
like you might say like wow living off
the land but hey i don't want to go to
hawaii i'd rather live in colorado i'd
rather in the mountains i'd rather live
but i can make set like what it what is
this person doing that i can make steps
to to get to my own goals
like yeah or to get to and just getting
to your own goals but finding
inspiration from everybody else that you
like there's just something about it
when you look at somebody and you're
like and you look at their life and
you're like what are they doing that's
wow that's so great and what pieces can
you take from that to like build your
own life that you love yeah and
realizing that you personally i know you
have trolls and people that have you
know commented negative things but 99.9
of people that you've changed their life
or inspired them to raise their kids
plant-based or become vegan or
move to hawaii like you know you've
changed but sometimes we focus on that
one percent you know and like i'm i'm
i've done it a million times or i see
that one comment you know or authors
like my mentor is an author and he's
like i can have a thousand good things
about my book and the amazon review that
one that hates me it like destroys my
whole day and it's like wow why is that
you know and and uh
i don't know well i once had i once was
going through a heated moment on social
media and i was talking to a friend who
gets plenty of that and she was like
look
there's there's not that many haters
just remind yourself that it's just that
it's just the negative ones are just
louder yeah and so it seems like more
when really you have like so much
overwhelming love and support because
it's i think it's easy to get to a place
where you start to just feel this
negative out like
oh all these people must have this
negative outlook about you when you
don't feel that inside
and so it's like it's just this
disconnect when really it's just like
that's not actually reality
because you could look at even like um
reviews on restaurants like people are
more likely to leave a negative review
than they are to take the time to go and
leave a positive review because if
you're upset by something you're like
more i don't know people just feel more
motivated to go
to say something they didn't like about
this restaurant as opposed to be like i
had a great experience i should go leave
a review like how often do you go on
amazon and like oh i really like the
product i'm gonna go leave this nice
review about this product like way way
way less so isn't that weird about our
human psyche of wanting to like i don't
know feel we feel more justified we feel
this like need to go and say what we
think is wrong with this this and this
and we're less likely to put something
positive out into something that you
actually really valued and admired why
is that
yeah well the the what comes to my mind
is like just the confidence in who you
are the confidence in what you're doing
and the word confidence when you when
you trace back to like the original
latin greek means trust like full trust
within and so
confidence is when we when we trust this
thing within us that we just know is our
truth you know raising your kids
plant-based right now you're just like
yo it's working like i don't have to
prove it to anyone right yeah i know my
spiritual experience with god is real i
don't have to prove it to anyone i'm to
justify it and so always coming back to
like what is the internal thing again
you know i don't know your broken record
but just where's the where was the
confidence lost where was the trust loss
within yourself and a lot of people have
imposter syndrome right that's like a
big uh term and i'm like yo if you're
feeling a posture syndrome you're doing
something right like you you are
creating yourself in a place that
doesn't exist yet because you believe in
the future version of yourself and so if
you're feeling impostor syndrome hell
yeah you're doing something right
because you're pushing yourself outside
your comfort zone to what you don't know
exists yet and and to always yeah come
back to um
you know just that confidence that inner
peace uh the only yeah the only thing
you have control over but i love that
that's a good point because you have to
go and do it like instead of just you
know just like imagine your dreams you
have to actually speak it and do it and
start making creativity yeah if everyone
i mean i don't know if you shared this
online but everyone knew you and
andrew's journey of how you guys came
here and hustled and like you know we're
just like yo we're confident that we
want to live on this island and we're
going to do whatever it takes to get
that you know and and you did and you
created it and no one sees that um and
no one understands that but that's like
every entrepreneur every author like i'm
always telling people like the reason
people are public speakers and authors
is because they engaged in life like
they showed up to friction they showed
up to events they showed up to things
they engaged and engagement creates
stories um not engagement like social
media engagement but engagement in
relationships yeah and so every book
that's written every public speaker is
because they failed at something or they
tried at something um and so just
encouraging people always to just engage
with life yeah that's really helpful i
think okay i have one more question i
think it's a great one to end it with
cool um what are some or what is a
lesson that you're in the middle of
learning right now
wow oh my goodness i am learning i mean
that's a big one because i'm learning um
to over communicate to really be better
at communicating um
when you uh yeah when you're unclear you
become unkind you know where this idea
where like you just have to
and the reason i'm saying that is
because i'm trying to start a business
that's like fully focused on people's
hearts and like this ministry of like
just loving people and i'm trying to
make it capitalistic and make it
sustainable and pay my friends that help
help people in this group and i keep
making mistakes and um
so yeah i'm just learning how to go you
know with extreme vulnerability and
leadership where i'm you know i can be
looked at as an example it's like bc's
ran all these amazing retreats they have
150 alumni from 20 countries like he's
done all this stuff what a leader and
i'm like yo i have no idea what i'm
doing you know as a parent too yeah like
i have no cl and i tell my team this i
have no idea what i'm doing y'all i'm
trying my best and i'm learning as i go
but don't look to me like man bc has
figured this out it's more of like yo i
i'm messing up all the time and please
have patience and grace and compassion
for me um and same with my wife when i
make mistakes and i drop the ball on my
mental health or my showing up for her
i'm learning right now that there's only
uh
you can disappoint a lot of people in
your life but there's some people you
can't and that's your kid and your wife
yeah and so i'm learning to disappoint a
lot of people um because of my
priorities of like yo i can disappoint
there's like this idea when you're
juggling life with all these balls
there's rubber balls that will bounce
back up like money or jobs but there's
glass balls and if that glass ball falls
and shatters that's my wife that's my
kid that's that's something that won't
bounce back up and so relearning my
priorities
letting a lot of people down in my
people pleasing
yeah you know i hate letting people down
i'm a people pleaser i love being there
for everyone and now i'm just like don't
return calls don't return text messages
and spend a lot more time with you know
my wife and my kid and uh you know
people might not like me for that but
people who really get me will
will understand yeah
yeah especially like you just have a new
baby yeah congratulations by the way you
have the cutest baby
he is so sweet three months old little
phoenix skywalker like he could not be
cuter so
but you yes the priorities of like
having your partner and your baby and
what's what are you gonna do to keep
that communication and life flowing
really well with a brand new baby
because it's a lot of work but you guys
do it seamlessly you guys are doing yeah
it's clear you guys are so so chill and
then like those good good vibrations
together
yeah we're learning i'm like i said i
think relationships are the greatest
wealth at the end of the day like that's
what i preach more than anything is is
relationships showing up for people
being there for people well
in the cosmic you know karmic energy of
the world or heavenly culture or
heavenly currency i call it sometimes
but
just show and people will always
reciprocate that in the long term like
for instance there's this group of high
school kids i mentored for four years
when they're in high school and there
this was like a long time ago and then
their parents reached out to me last
year and go hey bc we have this um 15
person cabin in breckenridge you can use
for retreats for free whenever you want
and so when i mentored these four kids
eight years ago i didn't know i wasn't
getting paid but eight years later the
parents were like hey we have this place
you can use for a retreat that would be
six thousand dollars for free and i'm
always encouraging people yo
relationships like i know capitalism i
know money runs the world sometimes but
show up with love and servanthood and
relationships and i promise you it'll
come full circle someday yeah and uh
just owe it and so i'm always learning
i'm always learning how to uh you know
value relationships um social media can
be tough sometimes because we want to
get back to people's dms or our
consumers these products but just being
like you know am i am i not going to
call my text my sister my mom my wife
all these things over these dms you know
um
so yeah i just i'm always like yeah the
priorities it's really hard it's a hard
balance because it's the type of job
where it never really ends like you
don't clock out and be like okay nine to
five there's really nothing else for me
to do or i finish my tasks i'm done
because there's always more you can be
doing so it's definitely a balancing act
that i've had to learn to just let go
and not get everything done and not do
as much as maybe i would like to do
um because of the priority of wanting to
be with my family totally and it's
forced first flow i'm always telling you
know issa and i are is this in flow like
coming here to hawaii we're like all
right do we have the budget for it does
it make sense or do we have to be
somewhere else but if it's in flow then
we're not forcing it and so always just
realizing like what are you forcing and
making happen or what is in flow with
like opportunities and yeah and that and
so um
yeah just yeah staying grounded
connected and and i don't want to ever
like tell you know make people feel like
i have it figured out or i'm i'm an
amazing husband or parent or a leader
because of x y and z but it's it's
because of my vulnerability because i'm
so strong in my weakness that i'm able
to ask for help and i'm able to tell my
team like hey guys i let you all down
like i we didn't make enough money i
can't pay you all like you know like
that's like super tough um and so yeah
just leading with vulnerability leading
from the heart um
it's tough that's no but that is the
that is the key because when you're
holding things in in your brain and not
not letting things out and being
vulnerable it really messes things up
yeah people will always meet you the
strongest like i always tell people in
this probably said before but the
strongest person in any room is the who
is whoever's the most vulnerable and
anytime you lead with vulnerability like
even when you're in a fight you know and
you're like i'm sorry actually i was
wrong someone's like wait we're supposed
to keep fighting you know like when
someone cuts you or you cut someone off
and or they cut you off and you like
wave peace sign you know you're not like
that mad at them and and they're so
counter-cultural of how hate and fear
works and um and so always trying to
interrupt where you can lead with one
and most people when you lead with
vulnerability they're like whoa like
your team if you're a leader or a ceo or
a coach or a parent just leading with
vulnerability people go whoa i had no
idea you were balancing that um i don't
want to fight with you i want to like
meet you where you're at so yes yeah at
the heart of this whole conversation it
really feels the
importance of vulnerability and tuning
into what you can do now instead of
pointing the fingers outward
and focusing on the day-to-day what
you're doing day-to-day um to show up
and helping others and turning the pain
into purpose yeah i love that yeah going
from surviving to thriving to really
that fight-or-flight mode if i'm just
trying to survive to
to uh yo i'm here on earth what are the
chances and i'm i love love being people
and i want to have fun i want to dance
like you know people are the work that
we do could be deep trauma work and
healing our parents
um relationships but then we're dancing
and having fun and then we're crying and
praying over each other and then we're
cuddle puddling and so it's like it's a
mix between all of it and it's all
beautiful and they're you're supposed to
have goofy funness and dance while
healing like it's part of it and that's
why i am so thankful for my partner
because whenever we do have moments one
of us will be having a moment where
we're
losing control or not grounding
ourselves getting in our heads right
because you have all these things
bubbling up of whatever's triggering you
um the other will help you like hey look
everything's okay look around you like i
got this and then the other one will
take over which is really helpful so i i
don't know if i can say that i love
everyone equally yeah yeah i i love that
you said that it's such an interesting
thing to compliment to contemplate right
but i'm like andre and i've been
together for 20 years and i this is our
20th year together like that is just
crazy that we've been together since we
were 15 and 60 like we have changed so
much that's incredible
with each other like a lot of times i
think high school relationships like the
reasons why they most time don't work
out because you're still figuring out
who you are and then you become in a way
and you're like no this isn't my person
but we like evolved and helped each
other grow
in our better best ways does that make
sense oh totally yeah and so i'm just so
thankful for that grounding presence and
relationship to like help me when i'm or
and for me to help him the other one can
just take over when we're starting to
lose sight of the presence yeah and your
two girlfriends came over the day and
you guys went on a trip where they can
help you in ways he can't and
so we just need each other we need
community we're we're tribal creatures
and we're emotional creatures and and
the more cerebral we get the more
disconnected the more you know we have a
microchips the size of a you know my
fingernail
that we lose that connection we think we
can outsmart our way out of everything
and so
um yeah just letting people know yeah
that vulnerability that community like
your girlfriends came over and it was
like medicine for you you know and then
andreas things that they don't have and
so we all need each other and we all
need to be vulnerable and community
together and that's why the church was
so beautiful for so long it did that so
well and it's you know it's kind of been
crippled because of certain things in it
but people everyone who i've ever talked
to that's left of the church they always
say they miss worship music singing
together and they miss like the
communion together and the family vibes
um they left for other reasons but
they're like man church has like certain
ingredients that are amazing
and so you know what our ministry and
our program what we do in our pursuing
purpose is a new idea of a church um
that has uh certain
you know things that we we didn't feel
safe in yeah that's fascinating it also
depends on the church too because
there's so many different types totally
yeah well i think we talked about a lot
i can't even believe it's been two hours
and this was so much fun
really really great that we got to just
like delve deep into these topics and
i'm just thankful for everything that
you're doing and sharing i'm constantly
finding inspiration from you so
everybody go follow his instagram um
it's just really really nice to like put
your feed in a way where you're like
getting uplifting information that's
like good reminders because a lot of
times we just lose touch we lose sight
of things because we're in such a
fast-paced world we got all these
different things driving us in a certain
way but when you like really tune in and
focus like what matters the most and um
this whole turning pain into purpose and
like helping others is really just at
the heart of it i think that's beautiful
so thanks for everything that you're
doing oh thanks so much it's been an
honor here in in your house and with
your kids the last couple days i'm
obsessed and in love with all your kids
and uh thank you so much for having me
and and this has been such a highlight
and so thank you my kids are obsessed
with you guys and that's a good
indicator i'm literally gonna miss them
i'm literally like i cannot wait to just
like see elvis the next time i see him
and all of them but oh i know they are
honestly gonna miss you you and elvis
should probably be pen pals yes that
would be so he made another pen pal um
earlier so
yeah that would be so much fun and they
they just love you guys and so you guys
really honestly are like living exactly
what you're talking about and we feel
that so thanks we've had such a good
time with you if you're listening i love
you i appreciate you um i just want to
celebrate you for sitting through this
whole episode and just leaning in i hope
it was a roller coaster of emotions and
and uh yeah i love you and i appreciate
you i see you and celebrate you for
diving in that's a it's a really intense
topic sometimes yeah talking about
forgiving our parents or healing our
heart and so uh if you're even in the
sphere of thinking of this
congratulations yeah thanks so much for
being here all right i think we'll end
it
yay
[Music]
you